I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello everybody and Angela, can I get a good morning? Yeah, you can.
我是珍娜·菲舍，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是Office女士们。大家好，安吉拉，能给我来一声亲切的早安吗？没问题，可以的。
Good morning, Jenna. Good morning, Sam. Good morning, Cassie. Good morning to you out there who's just starting your day and you're listening to us in your car or good evening to my night owls who are listening maybe by the fire, maybe with a glass of wine. I don't know. That was a beautiful picture that you just painted.
早安，珍娜。早安，萨姆。早安，卡西。早安，你们这些刚开始新的一天、正在车里听我们节目的人；或者晚安，我的夜猫子们，你们也许正坐在壁炉旁，也许正端着一杯葡萄酒在听。我不知道。你刚才描绘了一幅优美的画面。
Lady, guess what I did this morning? What? Something new. I've never done it before. Exercise. No, but I'm so tickled by that. I took a contrast shower. I don't know what that is.
女士，你猜我今天早上做了什么？什么？一些新鲜事。我以前从来没做过。锻炼？不是，但我对这个觉得很有趣。我洗了个冷热交替浴。我不知道那是什么。
I didn't know what it was. Is it a cold shower? It is an alternating hot and cold shower. Why would you do that? Okay, because it's supposed to have a bunch of health benefits and you know me, I'll try anything. I've gotten that shower at my grandparents' house in their guest bathroom. Does it just automatically alternate for you?
我以前也不知道那是什么。是冷水澡吗？是交替洗热水澡和冷水澡。你为什么要那样做？好吧，因为据说它有很多健康好处，而且你了解我，我什么都愿意尝试。我在我祖父母家的客用浴室里见过那种淋浴器。它会自动帮你切换吗？
It used to. It's like, oh, wait, wait, who just started the dishwasher? Don't shower. Oh, that's true at our house. Don't do a load of laundry before you get in the shower. Or you could have a contrast shower. Well, here's what it's supposed to do. It's supposed to improve blood flow, reduce systemic inflammation.
以前会。就像是，等等，等等，谁刚开了洗碗机？先别洗澡。哦，在我们家确实是这样。洗澡前别洗衣服。或者你也可以洗个冷热交替浴。好吧，这东西的作用原理是这样的。它应该可以改善血液循环，减少全身炎症。
It supports a connection between the brain and digestive system, but it's also just supposed to like energize you and kind of boost your immune system. I don't know. It's supposed to be beneficial and it's sort of based on a thing that athletes do, you know, where they do a cold plunge and a hot shower and things. Right. Oh my gosh. I wonder if Tom Brady does contrast showers.
它能促进大脑和消化系统之间的联系，但同时它也应该能让你充满活力并增强你的免疫系统。我不知道。它应该是有益的，这有点类似于运动员们做的事情，你知道的，他们会进行冷水浸泡和热水澡之类的。对的。哦天哪。我想知道汤姆·布雷迪洗不洗冷热交替浴。
Tom Brady does it all. That's what I mean. I'm telling you. He does it all. I should Google that. Do you think that's on the internet? His water drinking is on the internet? Okay.
汤姆·布雷迪什么都做。这就是我的意思。我跟你说。他什么都做。我应该去谷歌一下。你觉得互联网上会有这个吗？他喝水的事情都在互联网上吗？好吧。
It is. Okay. Well, listen. I did it this morning. You know what? Google Tom Brady's shower. Oh no. Don't Google that.
有的。好吧，听着。我今天早上做了。你知道吗？去谷歌一下汤姆·布雷迪的淋浴。哦，不。别去搜那个。
See what you get. Oh. Okay. Well. My husband's going to be like, why are you Googling? What is this search? They've given up on our search history. This is true.
看看你会搜出什么。哦。好吧。我丈夫会觉得，你为什么在谷歌上搜？这到底是什么搜索？他们已经对我们的搜索历史放弃希望了。确实如此。
Wait, wait. Do you feel energized? I kind of do. Okay. I do. I definitely felt energized when the freezing cold water hit my body after being in warm water. It was going to be called grumpy shower in my house.
等等，等等。你觉得充满活力了吗？我有点这种感觉。好吧。我觉得有。当温暖的水之后冰冷的水打在我的身体上时，我确实感到精力充沛。在我家，这本来要被叫做暴躁淋浴。
I had to sort of sing it out during the cold part. Like when the cold water hit me, I was like, and it's cold. Yes, it's cold. You turned into like a ye olde musical. I did. And my kids were like, what is mom doing today? Anyway, there you go. That's what I did today.
在水冷的那部分，我得一边唱歌一边撑过去。就像冷水打在我身上时，我在想，它真的很冷。没错，很冷。你变得像一出古老的音乐剧一样。我确实是。我的孩子们当时在想，妈妈今天在干什么？不管怎样，就是这样。这就是我今天做的事。
This morning. Did you do anything special or new or different, Ange? I did like 15 push-ups. This morning? Yeah. Before we got here. I remember John Krasinski used to do that. What?
今天早上。安吉，你有没有做什么特别的、新鲜的或不同的事情？我做了大概15个俯卧撑。今天早上？对的。在我们来这儿之前。我记得约翰·卡拉辛斯基以前经常那样做。什么？
Yes. In the mornings, he would get to work and before hair and makeup, he would do a bunch of push-ups and a bunch of sit-ups to energize himself in the morning. You don't remember that? No. I was always so impressed and I was inspired and I thought, oh, I should do that. I tried it one morning and I was like, I'm not doing that again. Well, I didn't do it either.
是的。早上他一到工作地点，在弄发型和化妆之前，他会做一堆俯卧撑和仰卧起坐，好让自己早上充满活力。你不记得了吗？不记得。我当时总是印象深刻，而且备受鼓舞，我想，哦，我也应该这么做。有一天早上我试了一下，然后我想，我再也不这样了。好吧，我其实也没做。
I was lying. I was doing a joke, but geez, John. Wow. I know. Should we get into this episode? Let's do it. The next episode today is Cafe Disco. It is season five, episode 27, written by Warren Lieberstein and Halstead Sullivan and
我是瞎编的。我在开玩笑，不过天哪，约翰。哇。我知道。我们要开始聊这一集了吗？开始吧。今天我们要聊的下一集是《咖啡迪斯科》。这是第五季第27集，由沃伦·利伯斯坦和霍尔斯特·沙利文编剧，
directed by Randall Einhorn. Would you like a summary? Yes. Concerned about the serious mood of his employees and just the general drab work environment at Dunder Mifflin, since Charles Minor left, Michael has decided to transform the former Michael Scott paper company into a Cafe Disco for socializing, dancing, and sipping espresso. Now, initially, nobody is interested, but it does slowly take off and ends up exceeding Michael's expectations.
兰德尔·艾因霍恩导演。你想听听剧情梗概吗？好的。由于担心员工们严肃的情绪，以及自从查尔斯·迈纳离开后邓德米夫林死气沉沉的工作环境，迈克尔决定将曾经的迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司改造为一个“咖啡迪斯科”，供大家社交、跳舞和品尝浓缩咖啡。一开始，没有人感兴趣，但它慢慢地火了起来，最后甚至超出了迈克尔的预期。
Meanwhile, Pam and Jim planned to secretly elope to Youngstown, Ohio and Dwight tries to help Phyllis with an injury. That's a lot. That's a lot happening. That's a lot. But it's a pretty simple episode, really. Fast fact number one was a fan question from Becca D. What was the inspiration for this episode?
与此同时，帕姆和吉姆计划秘密私奔去俄亥俄州的扬斯敦，而德怀特试图帮助受伤的菲利斯。信息量真大。这发生了太多事。信息量真大。但其实这也是相当简单的一集。第一条趣事来自粉丝贝卡·D的一个问题。这一集的灵感是什么？
We reached out to writers, Warren Lieberstein and Halstead Sullivan. Yes. Warren and Halstead were a fantastic writing team. I knew them for a long time from our days at the groundlings, and some of you guys listening to this know and some don't, but Warren and I used to be married and we're good friends and it was really fun to reminisce with both of them about this episode. Well, here's what he said about the inspiration for this episode, which I thought was amazing. He said that he and Halstead were pretty new writers at the time.
我们联系了编剧沃伦·利伯斯坦和霍尔斯特·沙利文。是的。沃伦和霍尔斯特是一个非常棒的编剧团队。我在格朗德林剧团的日子里就认识他们很久了，你们这些听节目的有些人知道，有些人不知道，但沃伦和我都曾经结过婚，我们现在是好朋友，和他们俩一起回忆这一集真的非常有趣。好吧，他是这样讲述这集的灵感的，我觉得太棒了。他说他和霍尔斯特当时都是相当年轻的编剧。
They joined in this season and they were tasked with coming up with an episode idea for what Michael Scott could do with this space that was formerly the Michael Scott paper company. He said that they were working in the writers' trailer with Brent Forrester and the three of them were kind of pitching ideas like, oh, what if it's a cafe? What if it's a disco? And they couldn't really decide. He said for some reason that day, Paul Lieberstein was also working in the writers' trailer. He was working out of BJ Novak's office that was sort of off of this communal area.
他们在这一季加入，任务是想出一个剧集创意，关于迈克尔·斯科特可以用原来迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的那个空间做些什么。他说他们当时正和布伦特·福斯特一起在编剧的拖车里工作，他们三个人一直在抛出各种想法，比如，哦，如果是个咖啡馆怎么样？如果是个迪斯科舞厅呢？他们实在拿不定主意。他说不知为什么那天保罗·利伯斯坦也在编剧的拖车里工作。他在BJ·诺瓦克的办公室里办公，那间办公室离这个公共区域不远。
So he could hear them going back and forth. Yes, exactly. And Warren said that Paul just suddenly came out of the office and said, it's a cafe and a disco. Michael Scott lives two things more than anything, coffee and dancing. It's a cafe disco. And then he turned around, went back into BJ's office and shut the door. And Warren said he remembers Brent turning to them and saying, well, you heard him.
所以他能听到他们争论不休。是的，完全正确。沃伦说保罗突然从办公室里走出来说，这就是个咖啡馆兼迪斯科舞厅。迈克尔·斯科特最喜欢两样东西，咖啡和跳舞。这就是咖啡迪斯科。然后他转过身，走回BJ的办公室并关上了门。沃伦说他记得布伦特转向他们说，好吧，你们都听到了。
And then the three of them just started outlining. What is a cafe disco to Michael Scott? It feels very much like something your dad would do, you know, like he'd come out as you're arguing and be like, it's both. Just do it. Yes, exactly. Well, it is more interesting being both, isn't it? And it's more Michael Scott that it would be a strange hybrid of two things.
然后他们三个人就开始列大纲了。对迈克尔·斯科特来说，什么是咖啡迪斯科？这感觉太像你爸爸会做的事了，你知道的，就像在你争论的时候他走出来说，两个都要。直接干就行。是的，完全正确。好吧，两者兼具更有趣，不是吗？而且由两种奇怪事物结合而成的混合体，也更符合迈克尔·斯科特的风格。
Yes. Halstead had some really great stuff to share as well. And he told us that they won an NAACP Image Award for Best Writing for a Comedy Series for this episode. This episode is really popular. When I told people that we were breaking down cafe disco and when we were trading emails with Randy Cordray about this one, he was like, I love this episode. I love the simplicity of it.
是的。霍尔斯特也有一些非常棒的事情要分享。他告诉我们，他们凭这一集获得了NAACP形象奖喜剧类剧集最佳编剧奖。这一集真的很受欢迎。当我告诉大家我们要剖析《咖啡迪斯科》时，当我们跟兰迪·科德雷就这一集交换电子邮件时，他说，我太喜欢这一集了。我喜欢它的简约。
It's just so beautiful. Yeah. Well, Halstead also said, Ang, guess what? There is a bakery in Oklahoma named Cafe Disco because they loved this episode so much. You can find them at cafe-disco.com. He said, have you ever heard of that? Have any of the other episodes had a bakery named after them? No, we've just heard of Shulalas, but I think they existed before Michael's Shulala.
它是如此美好。是的。嗯，霍尔斯特还说，安吉，你猜怎么着？俄亥俄州有一家面包店名叫“咖啡迪斯科”，因为他们太喜欢这一集了。你可以在 cafe-disco.com 找到他们。他说，你以前听说过这个吗？以前有哪集节目让面包店以它们的名字命名吗？没有，我们只听说过舒拉拉，但我认为他们在迈克尔的舒拉拉之前就存在了。
That's true. Fast fact number two, we shot this episode in four days instead of five. How did we do that? Randy shared that because all the work was so contained in that one tiny location of the cafe disco, there weren't like a ton of different ways to cover it with the camera. So we were able to kind of get it pretty quickly. So they would basically, rather than having some giant master shot and all these close-ups, they just covered it.
确实如此。趣事之二，我们只用四天而不是五天就拍完了这一集。我们是怎么做到的？兰迪分享说，因为所有的工作都集中在咖啡迪斯科那个极其狭小的取景地里，所以并没有成吨的各种角度的镜头需要拍摄。所以我们能很快搞定它。因此，他们基本上不是去拍什么巨大的全景镜头和所有这些特写，而是直接把它覆盖了。
He said it was kind of important that we do this in four days because this episode filmed the week right before Easter. And we were already meant to have Good Friday off for Easter weekend. And if we hadn't finished, we would have had to come back the Monday after Easter and pick up our fifth day. But that would have really thrown off our 100th episode, Company Picnic, which was happening the next week. It was a huge company move.
他说在四天内拍完这一点其实挺重要的，因为这一集拍摄的那周正好是复活节前夕。我们本来就预定在复活节周末的耶稣受难日放假。如果我们没有拍完，我们就得在复活节之后的星期一回来把第五天的戏补上。但那样就会彻底打乱我们下一周要拍的第100集《公司野餐》的计划。那可是公司的一次重大活动。
That would have been. Yeah. That would have been really hard. Yeah. That's what she said. So that leads me into fast fact number three, while there were no locations for this episode, no expensive stunts or props, there was a lot of music. And to get the rights to all the music that was in this episode was a very complicated
那可真是。是的。那会非常艰难。是的。她就是这么说的。这就引导我来到了趣事之三，虽然这一集没有外景，没有昂贵的特技或道具，但有很多音乐。要获得这一集中所有音乐的版权是一件非常复杂的事情。
thing to pull off. Randy shared that there are two kinds of music rights. There are sync rights, which is where you're going to play a song by the original artist. And that's all you're just going to hear their song. Okay. But then there are master rights. And that's what you need. If a character is going to sing or hum a song, sort of do their interpretation.
兰迪分享说，音乐版权有两种。一种是同步版权，也就是你打算播放原唱艺术家的歌曲。你听到的就只是他们的歌。好吧。但还有一种是母带版权。这是你需要的。如果某个角色要唱歌或哼唱一首歌，算是一种他们自己的演绎。
Yes. The artist. And Randy said that they wanted us to be able to sing along or hum along as we were dancing. And so we had to get both sync and master rights to every single song. There was only one song that appeared in the script. If you read the script, different scenes will say music is playing, Aaron presses play, but it doesn't say what song comes out except for one time in the script. What did it say?
是的。那位艺术家的。兰迪说，他们希望我们在跳舞时也能跟着唱或哼唱。所以我们必须获得每一首歌的同步版权和母带版权。剧本里原本只出现了一首歌。如果你读剧本，不同的场景会写着音乐正在播放，艾琳按下播放键，但除了剧本里的一次之外，它并没有写出播放的是什么歌。写的是什么？
The one song that appears in the script is Everybody Dance Now. And it's the song where Michael is playing it through the vents to get everybody to come down. And that song cost $40,000. Wow. And so Randy had our post production supervisor, Jake Oust, reach out to Universal Music, you know, because our show was made by NBC Universal. And see if they could get a list of songs that we could license for either free or for
剧本中出现的唯一一首歌是《Everybody Dance Now》。就是迈克尔通过通风管道播放这首歌来让大家下楼的那首歌。而这首歌花了4万美元。哇。所以兰迪让我们的后期制作主管杰克·奥斯特联系了环球音乐（你知道的，因为我们的节目是NBC环球制作的），看看他们能不能拿到一份歌曲名单，我们可以免费获得授权，或者花不了多少钱。
not that much money. And then he gave that list to Warren and Halstead and he said, what do you think? So Warren and Halstead made a list of like their dream music list. And then next to it, they would put a free alternative. And Randy sent this list over, it was really fascinating to look at. I'll just give one example. You know that opening scene when Michael's kind of dancing alone? Their first choice was Disturbia by Rihanna.
然后他把那份名单交给了沃伦和霍尔斯特，他说，你们觉得怎么样？于是沃伦和霍尔斯特列出了一份他们的梦想音乐清单。然后旁边，他们会写上一个免费的替代方案。兰迪把这份名单发了过来，看这个真的非常着迷。我只举一个例子。你知道开场那个迈克尔独自跳舞的场景吗？他们的第一选择是蕾哈娜的《Disturbia》。
Their free alternative, which appears in the show, is Car Wash. All right, for the most part, we had to go with their free alternative. I was going to say, I'm sure. The ultimate music budget for this episode was $85,200. Wow. Most of that money paid for Everybody Dance Now and YMCA. But Randy said that another perk of not having that fifth shoot day was that they were able to allocate some of that shoot days budget to music.
他们免费的替代方案（也就是节目中出现的）是《Car Wash》。好吧，大部分情况下，我们只能选择他们的免费替代方案。我正想说，我猜也是。这一集的最终音乐预算是85200美元。哇。大部分资金都用来支付《Everybody Dance Now》和《YMCA》了。但兰迪说，没有第五天拍摄日的另一个好处是，他们能够将那一天拍摄预算的一部分分配给音乐。
That makes sense. We were able to pull it off, but I mean, that is all Randy's job. He's just like a spreadsheet and he has to move things around. Numbers, numbers, numbers. And make it all happen. Well, my lady, those were some great fast facts. Thank you. Did you feel like they came from a person who had improved blood flow or maybe had a connection
这说得通。我们成功搞定了，但我的意思是，那全都是兰迪的工作。他就像一张电子表格，必须把事情挪来挪去。数字，数字，数字。然后把这一切变成现实。好吧，我的女士，这些都是很棒的趣事。谢谢你。你觉得它们听起来像是一个血液循环改善了或者大脑和消化系统之间有联系的人说出来的吗？
between their brain and digestive system? A hundred percent I did. Thank you. A hundred percent. I felt like that too. Yeah, my lady and not just lady. Oh, yeah. Now we know.
百分之百是的。谢谢你。百分之百。我也是这么觉得的。是的，我的女士，不只是女士。哦，是的。现在我们知道了。
You got a special one. Well, I think we should take a break and when we get back, someone has won an art contest and it's not Pam. I know, snark. We are back and before we dive into this episode, we have an exciting announcement. We do office ladies was nominated once again for the I heart radio podcast of the year award. We are so sick and excited.
你有一个特别的。好吧，我想我们该休息一下了，等我们回来，有人赢得了艺术比赛，而那个人不是帕姆。我懂，真刻薄。我们回来了，在我们深入探讨这一集之前，我们有一个激动人心的宣布。我们确实有，“办公室女士”再次获得iHeart电台年度播客奖提名。我们太开心也太激动了。
This award is based on votes from the public. That's you guys. It means so much to us. We won last year. Thanks to you. And you know, I'm not going to lie. I'd really like to win again. Lady.
这个奖项是根据公众投票决定的。也就是你们大家。这对我们意义重大。去年我们赢了。多亏了你们。而且你知道的，我不想撒谎。我真的很想再赢一次。女士。
Yeah. I'm not going to back to back. I do too. I want bookings. Back to back. Bookings. Oh my gosh. Yes.
是的。我不想连续两年都拿。我也想。我想连庄。连庄。哦天哪。是的。
I'm going to put my books in the middle of my words. Oh my gosh. All right. So here's the deal. The voting is open now. Basically you vote using Twitter. Okay. You just have to tweet with three hashtags, hashtag podcast of the year, hashtag I heart
我要把我的书放在我的话中间。哦天哪。好吧，事情是这样的。投票现在已经开始了。基本上你是用推特投票。好吧。你只需要发带有三个话题标签的推文，即 #podcast of the year，#i heart podcast awards，#office ladies。是的。那是最重要的一个。是的。
podcast awards, hashtag office ladies. Yes. That's the most important one. Yes. You can find the instructions, you know, in our show notes on our website and on Instagram, and you can find more information at I heart podcast awards.com. I want to win so much. I know.
你可以在我们的网站和Instagram的节目说明中找到说明，你也可以在 iheartpodcastawards.com 上找到更多信息。我太想赢了。我知道。
Is it tacky to say that? It's my truth. I don't think it's tacky. I just, I love making the podcast so much. I do too. I want to win an award for something I love doing. I know. And you know what?
说这话会显得很俗气吗？这是我的真心话。我不觉得俗气。我只是，我太喜欢制作这个播客了。我也是。我想为我热爱做的事情赢得一个奖项。我知道。而且你知道吗？
You don't want it to be an award that I make you because I did try to make you a lady. I know. It was a good effort. Thank you. You're welcome. You know what? You take one of your daughter's old Barbies and a hot glue gun and a little piece of wood you found.
你不会希望那是一个我亲手做给你的奖项，因为我确实试着给你做过一个，女士。我知道。那是一次很好的尝试。谢谢你。不客气。你知道吗？你拿一个你女儿旧的芭比娃娃、一把热熔胶枪，再加上你在哪儿找到的一小块木头。
Maybe it looks like an award. Maybe it looks like a cry for help. Okay. Should we get into this episode? Let's do it. How does it start? Well, we are in the Dunder Mifflin bullpen. When Erin, the new receptionist, squeals that she's won an art contest.
也许它看起来像个奖项。也许它看起来像是在呼救。好吧。我们应该开始聊这一集了吗？开始吧。它是怎么开始的？好吧，我们来到了邓德米夫林的办公区。当时新前台艾琳尖叫着说她赢得了一场艺术比赛。
Pam is not amused. Jenna was not amused. I had totally forgotten this cold open and I was like, oh my God. Dwight is such an ass in this cold open. He really is. And he's so tickled. He's so pleased with himself. I do want to point out, while Pam is exchanging looks with Dwight in their desk pod, Pam's
帕姆一点也高兴不起来。珍娜也一点没觉得好笑。我完全忘了这个冷开场，当时我想，天哪。德怀特在这个冷开场里真是个混蛋。他真的是。而且他太自鸣得意了。他对自己太满意了。我必须指出，当帕姆和德怀特在他们的办公桌隔间里交换眼神时，帕姆的
plant is on her desk as well as the little candy dispenser with jelly beans. Lady, we got an email from Audrey L who also noticed Pam's little candy dish. Audrey also mentioned that she really liked my hair in this scene. She thought it was super cute. Did you notice my hair? Yes. It's one of those ponytails where you do ponytail. And then you, how do you explain it?
植物放在她的桌子上，还有一个装满果冻豆的小糖果机。女士，我们收到了一封来自奥黛丽·L的电子邮件，她也注意到了帕姆的小糖果盘。奥黛丽还提到她真的很喜欢我这一幕的发型。她觉得超级可爱。你注意到我的发型了吗？是的。那是那种马尾辫，你先扎个马尾。然后你，你怎么解释呢？
Then you flip it through itself. Like a French. Oh my gosh. I 100% did my hair that way for one of my school dances, like back in the day. Do people still do that hairstyle? I don't know if they still do the hairstyle, Jenna, but it's clear to me we were meant to be best friends because I once went to a high school dance with a side ponytail. And that was my choice.
然后你把它从中间翻过去。就像法式盘发一样。哦天哪。我当年的某个学校舞会上100%就是这样扎头发的。现在的人还留那种发型吗？我不知道人们是否还留那个发型，珍娜，但很显然，我们注定要成为最好的朋友，因为我曾经梳着单侧马尾去参加过高中舞会。那是我的选择。
I styled it like that on purpose. Well, we often did ponytails when there was a standalone cold open. It was a way to differentiate Pam's look and hair from the actual episode. So something, if you feel like it, you could track it and see when Pam has ponytails. It's usually the cold open. We did a lot of that with Angela Martin too. Just something different. It wasn't always a ponytail, but just something a little different for a cold open.
我就是故意那样设计的。好吧，当有独立的冷开场时，我们经常扎马尾辫。这是一种将帕姆的外观和发型与实际剧集区分开来的方法。所以如果有的话，你可以追踪一下，看看帕姆什么时候梳马尾辫。通常都是在冷开场。我们在安吉拉·马丁身上也做了很多这样的尝试。只是换点不同的东西。不一定总是马尾辫，但对于冷开场来说总会有一些微小的不同。
I remember Angela early in the series, you did a lot of buns and then they started to give you headaches. Horrible headaches, guys. But then I remember you were like, you know what, I'll do a bun for the cold open. Yeah. I didn't want to get rid of this hairstyle for Angela completely because it had been so established. But if you did a bun for a cold open, you only had to wear it for like four hours.
我记得在剧集早期安吉拉你梳过很多发髻，后来那些发型开始让你头疼。可怕的头疼，伙计们。但后来我记得你说过，你知道吗，我会在冷开场时梳个发髻。是的。我并不想彻底放弃安吉拉的这个发型，因为它已经太深入人心了。但如果你为冷开场梳个发髻，你只需要戴它大约四个小时。
Exactly. Our one full day, maybe. Yes, but not five days. All day. Not five days for 12 hours. I guess I just have one more question about this, which is, did you ever wear a bun to a school dance? No.
没错。我们完整的一天，也许吧。是的，但不是五天。整整一天。不是连续五天每天12小时。我想我关于这个只有一个问题，那就是，你以前去学校舞会时梳过发髻吗？没有。
No, but I did wear an updo the year we won the SAG Award and I was super pregnant. I had an updo. I liked that on you. That looked nice. Thank you. Yeah. I was just so pregnant. I just was like, do I have to get an evening gown?
没有，不过在我们赢得美国演员工会奖的那一年我确实梳了个盘发，当时我怀孕快临盆了。我梳了个盘发。我很喜欢你那个发型。那看起来挺好看的。谢谢你。是的。我当时只是肚子太大了。我当时就在想，我非得穿晚礼服吗？
But no, no buns at high school dances. I don't think I did either. It's a bold choice. It is. In high school. True. Yeah. Well, this episode starts with Michael dancing by himself to car wash in what was Michael
不过没有，高中舞会上没有发髻。我想我也没有。这是一个大胆的选择。确实是。在高中时。确实。好吧，这一集一开始是迈克尔在原本属于迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的地方独自伴随着《Car Wash》跳舞。
Scott Paper Company? All I could think about when I was watching him in there dancing was, look at all the stuff Phil Shea had to get. He had to get an espresso maker, then the little espresso coffee cups and saucers, napkins, espresso coffee, the boombox, a lava lamp, a little desk lamp, a lay, all kinds of coffee accessories, an empty cheese puff container, a couple of chairs, and then eventually he'd have to get a tiny disco ball and some kind of the, I don't know, were they red chili pepper lights?
当我看着他在里面跳舞时，我脑子里想的全是，看看菲尔·谢伊得弄来多少东西。他得弄一台浓缩咖啡机，然后是小浓缩咖啡杯和托盘、餐巾纸、浓缩咖啡、手提音响、一个熔岩灯、一盏小台灯、一条夏威夷花环、各种各样的咖啡配件、一个空的膨化玉米果容器、几把椅子，然后最后他还得弄一个微型迪斯科球和某种，我不知道，那是红辣椒灯吗？
Oh, yeah. Yeah. So Phil Shea, once again, simple episode, but he had all these little things he had to get. A lot of details. Yeah. Michael comes up to the office now and he would like to have lunch with someone. Yeah.
哦，是的。是的。所以菲尔·谢伊，再一次，虽然是个简单的单集，但他有这么多小玩意儿必须准备。很多细节。是的。迈克尔现在来到办公室，他想找个人一起吃午饭。是的。
He really loved lunches at Michael Scott Paper Company. You know, I have to say, why did the camaraderie between Pam, Michael, and Ryan have to end? I was loving it. Now it seems like, you know, their relationship is just kind of back where it started. I think that happens sometimes. I guess it does. They've sort of returned to their old roles, their routines. Well then Michael has this kind of depressing talking head where he says, at Dundermiflin,
他真的很喜欢在迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司吃午饭。你知道，我不得不说，为什么帕姆、迈克尔和瑞恩之间的情谊必须结束呢？我太喜欢了。现在看来，你知道，他们的关系好像回到了最初的起点。我想有时候确实会这样。我想是的。他们有点回到了各自的老角色、老套路里。接着迈克尔有一段非常令人沮丧的“对着镜头独白”，他说，在邓德米夫林，
there is a very strict no lunch with the boss policy, and I don't know who instituted it. That broke my heart. I know. You know, Ryan says he can't have lunch with Michael because he's doing five small meals a day. That was a really popular thing. Have you ever done that? I think that's just how I naturally eat.
有一条非常严格的“不准和老板一起吃午饭”的规定，我不知道是谁定下的。这让我心碎。我懂。你知道，瑞恩说他不能和迈克尔一起吃午饭，因为他实行的是一天五餐的小分量饮食法。那阵子这可真流行。你这么做过吗？我觉得这只是我天生吃东西的方式。
I thought of you when he said that. That is not how I naturally eat. I just sort of snack all day. Here's what I need to get through a day. I need three full meals. I also need a snack, and I'm going to need a dessert. I forget to eat until about noon, and then I'm crazy hungry, and then I don't understand forgetting to eat.
他说这话时我想到了你。我可不是天生这么吃东西的。我只是整天吃点零食。我是这样度过一天的：我需要三顿正餐。我还需要一份点心，而且我还需要一份甜点。我常常忙到中午左右才想起来吃东西，然后就会饿得要命，接着我就无法理解怎么会忘了吃饭。
I wake up, and the first thing I think of is when am I eating? It's like constantly on my mind. I'm already thinking about the yogurt that I brought for our snack the next time we take a break on the podcast. I'm like so food-centered. Well, no one wants to have lunch with Michael. They say they have a lot of work to do. Michael starts doing his robot.
我一醒来，脑子里想的第一件事就是什么时候吃饭？这感觉就像一直在我的脑子里盘旋。我已经在想着我带来的酸奶了，那是等下我们在播客中休息时要吃的点心。我真是个名副其实的“吃货”。好吧，没人想和迈克尔一起吃午饭。他们说有很多工作要做。迈克尔开始表演他的机器人。
Pam has to take the battery out, or he'll just keep going, I guess. During this scene, at three minutes, three seconds, there is a shot of my outfit. I have to point it out. I noticed it. I'm wearing a gray cardigan, a gray blouse, a gray skirt, and Jenna, I'm wearing gray tights. I am wearing something on my legs. I never wore anything on my legs.
帕姆不得不把电池拿出来，否则他就会一直跳下去，我想是的。在这场戏里，在三分三秒的时候，有一个我服装的特写。我必须指出来。我注意到了。我穿着一件灰色开衫、一件灰色衬衫、一条灰色裙子，詹娜，我还穿着灰色紧身裤。我腿上穿了东西。我以前从来不在腿上穿任何东西。
I don't know why in this episode, but I do. And I wonder if it was really cold, because we were shooting this in what sounds like March, early April, if it was around Easter, and that is cold in LA. That's like our cold stretch. I know. I just got excited, guys, because I would never wear the pantyhose they put in my trailer. I was anti-pantyhose. Also, maybe did you notice my shoes?
我不知道为什么在这集里会这样，但我确实穿了。我在想是不是真的很冷，因为我们拍这场戏的时候听起来像是三月，或者四月初，如果是在复活节前后的话，那洛杉矶的春天可真冷。那就像是我们的寒潮时期。我懂。我刚才太兴奋了，伙计们，因为我绝不会穿他们放在我化妆车里的连裤袜。我是坚决反对连裤袜的。还有，你注意我的鞋子了吗？
I'm going to bring them up later. I didn't. Okay. But you're going to make me wait. Yeah. Okay. So, at three minutes, 10 seconds, Erin finds a map of Youngstown, Ohio, in the printer. And she brings it to Dwight, and he says, this is a map to the superior court, and the
我待会儿再提。我没注意。好吧。但你要让我等着。好吧。所以，在三分十秒的时候，艾琳在打印机里发现了一张俄亥俄州扬斯敦的地图。她把它拿给德怀特，德怀特说，这是一张去高等法院的地图，而
only reason to go there is if you've been charged with a crime, or if you want to try to get a learner's permit at 14 and a half. But this scene starts with Erin saying, hi, guys, how are you doing? And then Dwight is like, Erin, how many times do I have to tell you? It's not necessary for you to ask us how we are every time you interact with us. We got a fan question from Lloyd C. in Australia, who said, I recall in a previous podcast, it was mentioned that Rainn Wilson made a big announcement about not needing to ask how his weekend was at the start of each week.
去那里的唯一原因，要么是你被控犯罪，要么是你想在十四岁半时就去考取初学者驾照。但这场戏开始时，艾琳说，嗨，伙计们，你们过得怎么样？然后德怀特就说，艾琳，我要跟你说多少次？没必要每次跟我互动时都问我们过得怎么样。我们收到了来自澳大利亚的劳埃德·C.的一个粉丝提问，他说，我记得在之前的播客中提到过，雷恩·威尔逊曾发表过一个重大声明，说不需要在每周开始时问他的周末过得怎么样。
He said, just assume it was good. Is this bit at Rainn's desk between Dwight and Erin may be based on Rainn's weekend question rule? I don't know, but I will tell you the minute I saw that, it was the first thing I thought of. Same here. I was like, that just feels like Rainn. Yes.
他说，直接假设它过得很好就行了。德怀特和艾琳在雷恩办公桌前的这段戏，是不是可能取材于雷恩关于周末的提问规则？我不知道，但我可以告诉你，我看到它的那一刻，这就是我脑子里浮现的第一件事。我也是。我当时就想，这太有雷恩的感觉了。没错。
Yes. We also had a fan catch from Samantha R. who said that Dwight mentions one of the reasons you would go to the courthouse is to obtain a learner's permit at age 14 and a half instead of 15. However, you have to be 16 to obtain a learner's permit. This has always stood out to me. And then Hannah W. said, I'm from Ohio and the minimum age for a learner's permit is 15 and a half, well, I had to know.
是的。我们还收到了萨曼莎·R.的粉丝纠错，她说德怀特提到去法院的原因之一是为了在15岁而不是14岁半时获得初学者驾照。然而，你必须满16岁才能获得初学者驾照。这一点一直让我觉得很突兀。然后汉娜·W.说，我是俄亥俄州人，获得初学者驾照的最低年龄是15岁半，好吧，我必须弄个明白。
Okay. Here's the deal. You must be 15 and a half to obtain a learner's permit to drive a car. However, you can get a learner's permit for a motorized bicycle at the age of 14. All right. That's next year for Isabelle and Jack. And I cannot imagine those two, my kids, with anything motorized. Well, I don't want them on anything that moves faster than a bicycle.
好吧。事情是这样的。你必须满15岁半才能获得汽车的初学者驾照。不过，你可以在14岁时获得机动自行车的初学者驾照。好吧。伊莎贝尔和杰克明年就能考了。我简直无法想象那两个小家伙，我的孩子们，骑着任何带发动机的东西。好吧，我不希望他们骑任何比自行车移动得更快的东西。
If you were in Youngstown, Ohio, they could get a learner's permit. Oh my gosh. Dwight had a really funny deleted talking head here. Oh, I can't wait. I'm going to read it to you. It cracked me up. Very sarcastically Dwight says, oh no, I love Ohio. Next time you're there, say hi to my cousin, Emile, and then kick him in the groin area
如果你在俄亥俄州扬斯敦，他们就能拿到初学者驾照了。哦，天哪。德怀特在这里有一段非常搞笑的被删掉的独白。哦，我等不及了。我要读给你听。把我逗得前仰后合。德怀特非常讽刺地说道，哦不，我爱俄亥俄州。下次你去那里的时候，代我向我的表弟埃米尔问好，然后踢他的裆部，
because he's a cheat and a ball hog. And if he's still married to Clarissa, kick her in the groin area, too, because she's a heartbreaking tart and a ball hog. Oh my gosh. What were they playing? Did they play like basketball and Clarissa and Emile, like hog the ball? What is happening in Ohio? Dwight's family is a mystery and very complex.
因为他是个骗子，还是个独占球权的自私鬼。如果他和克拉丽莎还没离婚，也顺便踢她的裆部，因为她是个让人心碎的荡妇，也是个独占球权的自私鬼。哦，天哪。他们在玩什么？他们是在打篮球吗？然后克拉丽莎和埃米尔独占球权？俄亥俄州到底发生了什么？德怀特的一家真是一个谜，而且关系非常复杂。
Who knew he had relatives in Ohio? And also, apparently from this talking head, if Dwight were in Ohio and saw Clarissa and Emile, he would kick them in the groin area, both of them. Incidentally, I am currently reading a book about Akron, Ohio. Okay. It's by this amazing writer, this guy, David Giffels. He lives in Ohio and he and his wife decided to put a low ball offer on this like broken down house mansion, like literally when he describes it, there's like sunshine coming
谁知道他在俄亥俄州还有亲戚呢？而且根据这段独白，显然如果德怀特在俄亥俄州看到克拉丽莎和埃米尔，他会踢他们的裆部，两个人都踢。顺便说一句，我目前正在读一本关于俄亥俄州阿克伦的书。好的。作者是一位了不起的作家，这个人叫大卫·吉菲尔斯。他住在俄亥俄州，他和妻子决定对这栋破旧的豪宅出一个很低的报价，真的，当他描述它的时候，阳光就从
through this thing. Right, right. It's like the money pit. 100% the money pit. And the book is just a memoir of them fixing it up absolutely by themselves while they lived in it. I don't know. It's just this amazing book and I'm loving it.
这个东西透进来。对，对。这就像是电影《钱坑》里的房子。100%就是《钱坑》。这本书就是他们一边住在里面，一边完全靠自己把它修缮好的回忆录。我不知道。这真是一本了不起的书，我太喜欢了。
I had thought of it for my dad who's a big like DIY fixer person. I gave it to him for his birthday and he loved it. So I like Ohio. At least through the eyes of this book, for sure. Are you and I going to get a fixer upper in Ohio? No, I bought a fixer upper in LA and spent a year. And so maybe that's also why I'm relating to it, but yeah. Same.
我曾为我爸考虑过这本书，他是一个狂热的DIY修理达人。我把它作为生日礼物送给了他，他非常喜欢。所以我挺喜欢俄亥俄州的。至少通过这本书的视角来看，确实如此。你和我打算去俄亥俄州买个需要翻新的老房子吗？没有，我在洛杉矶买了一个需要翻新的房子，花了一年时间。所以也许这也是我能对它产生共鸣的原因，但确实如此。一样。
You and I love a home project, man. I got a fixer upper too and I'm still fixing it up. Pam and Jim are going to have this talking head where they say there are other reasons to go to Ohio. And the reason they're going is because they're getting married and it's the closest place that they can get a marriage license without the three day waiting period. This talking head is so cute. I mean, my gosh, we are so cutie pie in this.
你和我都很喜欢做家居翻新项目，天哪。我也买了一个需要翻新的房子，而且我还在修缮它。帕姆和吉姆有一段独白，他们在其中说，去俄亥俄州还有其他原因。他们去那里的原因是因为他们要结婚了，那是离他们最近、不用等三天就能拿到结婚证的地方。这段独白太可爱了。我是说，天哪，我们在里面简直是两个小可爱。
Jim and Pam at peak cuteness. Yes. They just feel like the wedding planning, it's getting really complicated, it's getting really expensive. And Jim said at breakfast, I want to marry you today. So they're going to go for it. It's so sweet. It's very much young love to me.
吉姆和帕姆的可爱巅峰。是的。他们只是觉得筹备婚礼变得越来越复杂，越来越昂贵。吉姆在早餐时说，我想今天就娶你。所以他们决定放手去做了。太甜了。在我看来，这非常有年轻人的恋爱感觉。
Yeah. Yeah. You're in wedding planning, having that moment where you get overwhelmed and you're like, why are we doing this? I know. So I could relate as well. I mean, Josh and I, we went to the courthouse and stay in a Barbara a month before our wedding and we're like, just get married.
对。对。你在筹备婚礼时，会有那种感到不知所措的时刻，然后你会想，我们为什么要这么做？我懂。所以我也能感同身受。我是说，我和乔许在婚礼前一个月去了圣巴巴拉的法院，我们当时就想，直接结婚吧。
Let's just take that off the plate, you know? Then I guess the wedding is more of a celebration. Exactly. You can separate those two moments. Yeah, we did that. I loved it. We had a fan catch about this bit of info about Youngston, Ohio as well. Mary C wrote in and said, I've lived in Youngston, Ohio all my life.
把这件事从待办清单上划掉，你知道吗？然后我觉得婚礼就会更像是一场庆祝活动。没错。你可以把这两个时刻分开。对，我们就是这么做的。我超喜欢。我们也有一个粉丝纠错，是关于俄亥俄州扬斯敦的这个信息的。玛丽·C.写信说，我一生都住在俄亥俄州扬斯敦。
I got married in Youngston and you cannot get a marriage license the same day here. It takes 10 to 14 working days, but I do love the Youngston reference. You can get a same day marriage license in Las Vegas. Well, Mary L wrote in to say that there is no waiting period, that it's true. And then Andrea V said, I did a little deep dive and there is no superior court in Youngston, Ohio. So a lot of mail about these Youngston, Ohio details. Yes.
我在扬斯敦结的婚，你根本无法在那里当天拿到结婚证。这需要10到14个工作日，但我确实很喜欢扬斯敦这个梗。你在拉斯维加斯可以当天拿到结婚证。好吧，玛丽·L.写信说没有等待期，这是真的。然后安德里亚·V.说，我做了一点深入研究，俄亥俄州扬斯敦根本没有高等法院。所以我们收到了很多关于这些俄亥俄州扬斯敦细节的邮件。是的。
So here I'm going to clear it up for everybody. Andrea's right. There is no superior court. But there is the Youngston Municipal Court. And as far as marriage licenses go, I went to the city applications, frequently asked questions, and it says that while there is a Youngston Municipal Court, that's not where you go for your marriage license anyway. You need to apply for a marriage license at the Mahoning County Probate Court.
所以我现在要为所有人澄清一下。安德里亚是对的。没有高等法院。但是有扬斯敦市法院。至于结婚证，我查看了市政府申请的常见问题解答，上面说虽然有扬斯敦市法院，但那并不是你办结婚证的地方。你需要去马霍宁县遗嘱认证法院申请结婚证。
And even if you're out of state, you can get a marriage license there as long as you have your wedding ceremony in Mahoning County. You need to be 18 years old. You're going to need your Social Security card, two forms of identification. You're going to have to state your place of birth, your parents' names, no blood test, and it costs $43 cash, 43 cash, cash, no Venmo, not PayPal, no, no, cash only, not in Mahoning. Nope. How long is your marriage license valid in Youngston, Ohio?
而且即使你来自外州，只要你在马霍宁县举行婚礼仪式，你也可以在那里获得结婚证。你需要满18岁。你需要带上你的社保卡和两份身份证明。你必须说明你的出生地、父母的名字，不需要验血，费用是43美元现金，43块现金，现金，不接受Venmo，也不用PayPal，不，不，只收现金，马霍宁县不兴这个。不。你在俄亥俄州扬斯敦的结婚证有效期是多久？
Are you asking me? The website asked and answered. It is valid for 60 days. And here it is. There is no waiting period before you can use your marriage license in Mahoning County. There it is. There it is. Everything you ever needed to know about getting a marriage license in Ohio, specifically
你是在问我吗？网站上问过并且回答了。有效期是60天。就是这样。就是这样。关于在俄亥俄州获取结婚证，你所需要知道的一切，具体来说就是
Mahoning County, correct. During all of this Ohio conversation, Michael is on a dance break, guys, and Aaron is going to bring him some messages and he's like, no, no, no, no work here. They have Expresso, they come upstairs and Michael decides to tell the group about the downstairs room. Yeah. He and Aaron entered, they both have their little Espresso cups, and by the way, I just noticed that you say it the way I used to say it.
马霍宁县，没错。在所有这些关于俄亥俄州的对话中，迈克尔正在进行舞蹈休息时间，伙计们，艾琳给他带去了一些留言，而他说，不，不，不，这里不办公。他们有浓缩咖啡，他们走上楼来，迈克尔决定向大家介绍楼下的房间。是的。他和艾琳走了进去，他们俩都拿着他们的小浓缩咖啡杯，顺便说一句，我刚注意到你发这个词的音就像我以前一样。
Oh, I put an X in it. You say Expresso. I know, it's Espresso. But a lot of people say Expresso. I know. And I think it's okay. I think we should let it go. It's Espresso.
哦，我在里面加了个X音。你读的是“Ex-presso”。我知道，是“Espresso”。但很多人都读成“Ex-presso”。我知道。而且我觉得这没关系。我觉得我们应该随它去吧。是“Espresso”。
Espresso. Espresso. We had a fan catch from Hannah C, who says in this episode, Aaron drinks an Espresso, but in season nine, episode 11, the office gets an Espresso machine and Aaron says she's never had one before. Oh, good catch. I thought that was good. Yeah.
Espresso。Espresso。我们收到了来自汉娜·C.的粉丝纠错，她说在这集里，艾琳喝了一杯浓缩咖啡，但是在第九季第十一集里，办公室来了一台浓缩咖啡机，艾琳却说她以前从来没喝过。哦，好细心的纠错。我觉得这挺好的。是的。
Michael's going to give a big speech now. He is. And I absolutely love this runner. To me, this is classic, the office bullpen back and forth where everyone is chiming in, where it really gets funny to me is when Dwight does his Jack Nicholson impression, which I thought Rain did a really good job. I thought so too. And this takes us down this road where Meredith is like, wait, it's a haunted coffee house?
迈克尔现在要发表长篇大论了。他确实要讲。我非常喜欢这个连贯的情节。对我来说，这是经典的办公室员工闲聊互动，大家都在七嘴八舌地插话，真正让我觉得搞笑的是德怀特模仿杰克·尼克尔森的时候，我觉得雷恩模仿得非常棒。我也这么觉得。这把我们带向了一个方向，梅雷迪思说，等等，这是一个闹鬼的咖啡馆吗？
Michael's like, no, no, Dwight's confusing you. It's more of a disco. And then Andy says, a haunted disco. Michael's like, with coffee, but without the haunted. And then Phyllis is like, it's a combo dance house coffee bar. And Michael says, it's a daytime disco on the ground floor of an industrial office building. And Aaron goes, it's a cafe disco. Michael's like, exactly.
迈克尔说，不，不，德怀特把你搞糊涂了。这更像是一个迪斯科舞厅。然后安迪说，一个闹鬼的迪斯科舞厅。迈克尔说，带咖啡的，但是没有闹鬼的元素。然后菲莉丝说，这是一个集舞蹈和咖啡吧于一体的综合场所。迈克尔说，这是工业办公楼底楼的一个日间迪斯科舞厅。艾琳接着说，这是一个“咖啡迪斯科（Cafe Disco）”。迈克尔说，完全正确。
And then Kevin says, so like a disco cafe and Michael's like, no, not even close. These are more of my favorite kind of scenes to shoot. And immediately after this scene, there would have been a Stanley talking head where he says this, how did I end up back in crazy town? And then immediately after that would have been an Oscar talking head. And Oscar said this, it still seems really confusing as a concept. That would be Oscars like take on it. He's very practical and literal.
然后凯文说，所以就像一个迪斯科咖啡馆？迈克尔说，不，差得远呢。这些更排在我最喜欢拍摄的场景的前列。紧接着这场戏之后，本来应该有一个斯坦利对着镜头的独白，他说：我怎么又回到了这个疯狂的小镇？紧接着那段本来应该是一个奥斯卡对着镜头的独白。奥斯卡是这样说的：从概念上讲，这看起来还是让人很困惑。这就是奥斯卡对这件事的看法。他非常务实且注重字面意思。
Right. Like what is your business plan? This seems confusing. Then Michael tries to entice everyone to come. He offers them all the espresso you can eat. Oh, well done, Angela. Thank you. And this is when this awesome runner would have started that I'm calling Kevin's bacon
对，就像你的商业计划是什么？这让人很困惑。然后迈克尔试图吸引每个人都来。他向他们提供所有你能吃得下的浓缩咖啡。哦，干得漂亮，安吉拉。谢谢。就在这时，这个超棒的连贯情节开始了，我把它叫做凯文的培根
runner. Oh, Kevin bacon runner. Kevin bacon runner. It's in deleted scenes. Kevin sees Lynn at the elevators and they have this exchange. Hi, Kevin. Hi, Lynn. Did you have bacon for breakfast?
情节。哦，凯文·培根情节。凯文·培根情节。它出现在被删减的片段中。凯文在电梯旁看到了琳，他们有了这样一段对话。嗨，凯文。嗨，琳。你早餐吃培根了吗？
No. Oh, because you smell like bacon. I didn't think I did. How's everything going? Great. I'm going down the hall to this office to see Michael. There's three espressos. I would invite you, but I remember that you just want to be friends.
没有。哦，因为你闻起来像培根。我倒不觉得自己身上有味。一切都好吗？挺好的。我要去大厅这边的办公室找迈克尔。那里有三杯浓缩咖啡。本想邀请你的，但我记得你说过只想做朋友。
We can still. Are you sure that you didn't eat bacon? Yes. Whatever it is, I like it. Okay. So then he walks away and Lynn has a talking head. Did she eat bacon? You got to hear it.
我们还可以。你确定你没吃培根吗？是的。不管是什么，我都挺喜欢的。好吧。然后他走开了，琳有了一段对着镜头的独白。她吃培根了吗？你得听听这个。
Yes. I had some bacon this morning. I just didn't think it was anyone's business. Isn't that funny? But wait, it gets better. Kevin just can't get Lynn and the bacon smell off his mind and he asks her out. I love the smell of bacon on a woman. Hey, Lynn, it's Kevin.
对。我今天早上吃了一些培根。我只是觉得这不关别人的事。是不是很搞笑？等等，还有更好玩的。凯文对琳和培根的香味念念不忘，于是他约她出去。我喜欢女人身上有培根的香味。嘿，琳，我是凯文。
I was thinking about going and getting a coffee at the Cafe Disco. I'm wondering if you want to go with. Wow. Yes. So later when you see them slow dancing and then when they have a full on make out, it all started with this bacon scene by the elevators. That was amazing. What a find.
我在想去咖啡迪斯科买杯咖啡。我想知道你想不想一起去。哇。好吧。所以后来当你看到他们跳慢舞，然后看到他们激情热吻时，这一切都始于电梯旁这段关于培根的戏。太棒了。真是个重大发现。
I know. I so enjoyed it. Well, when Michael is kind of describing his inspiration for this disco and how it's going to bring people together and it's going to make people happy and kind of break them out of their funk, I have to say that he has right on about disco in general. I was reading a bunch about disco and listening to disco music when I was prepping this episode. This is very you. I know.
我知道。我太喜欢了。嗯，当迈克尔在描述他举办这个迪斯科舞厅的灵感，以及它将如何把人们聚集在一起，让大家快乐并帮他们摆脱沮丧情绪时，我必须说，关于迪斯科本身，他的看法完全正确。我在为这集做准备时，读了很多关于迪斯科的文章，也听了很多迪斯科音乐。这非常符合你的风格。我知道。
I like the sound of Scranton. It really is. And here is what I found out and I pulled a couple of quotes because I loved them. So disco in general is just a very inclusive and accepting culture. It was very communal. It was more than just music. It really was a cultural movement. And there's this book called Turn the Beat Around by author Peter Shapiro and he called
我喜欢斯克兰顿的声音。确实如此。以下是我发现的内容，我摘录了几句名言，因为我太喜欢它们了。所以迪斯科总体来说是一种非常具有包容性和接纳性的文化。它非常具有社群感。它不仅仅是音乐。它真的成了一种文化运动。有一本书叫《转动节拍（Turn the Beat Around）》，作者是彼得·夏皮罗，他把
disco, quote, the embodiment of the vision of peace that the 60s yearned for. An article in Timeline.com went on to say, disco was created by black and Latino musicians in the early 70s and popularized by mostly gay DJs for a mostly gay crowd celebrating new freedoms earned by the gay rights movement. And finally, now Rogers, the guitarist for the hit disco band Chic said, this was the world I wanted to live in where everybody was cool with everyone. That was because of the music. That was disco.
迪斯科称作“60年代所渴望的和平愿景的具体化”。Timeline.com网站的一篇文章接着写道，迪斯科是由黑人和拉丁裔音乐家在70年代初创造的，并主要由同性恋DJ为主要由同性恋组成的群体进行推广，以庆祝同性恋权利运动赢得的新自由。最后，热门迪斯科乐队“时髦合唱团（Chic）”的吉他手纳尔士·罗杰斯说，这就是我想要生活的世界，每个人都能和所有人合得来。这就是音乐带来的效果。那就是迪斯科。
That was disco. I mean, I'm a kid of the 70s, you know, my mom and her friends were so excited because they got to go see Donna summer in concert disco, the queen of disco. My mom said it was a phenomenal show. How cool that your mom got to see her perform live. I know. I would have loved to have gone with my mom. I was too little because I love disco.
那就是迪斯科。我是伴随着70年代长大的一代人，你知道的，我妈妈和她的朋友们当时兴奋极了，因为她们能去现场看唐娜·萨默的演唱会——迪斯科女王。我妈妈说那是一场无与伦比的演出。你妈妈能去看她现场演出，真是太酷了。我知道。我本来很想跟我妈一起去的。我当时太小了，因为我太喜欢迪斯科了。
But Angela Martin, of course, is not a fan of Michael pulling everyone off of work and taking them down to his disco cafe. Cafe disco. His cafe disco. And you'll see that Kevin is there very messily making his espresso. And it's because he's waiting for Lynn. Had you seen all of that deleted runner, you would know he's hoping Lynn will show up. In fact, in the shooting draft, the scene is more extended.
但是安吉拉·马丁当然不喜欢迈克尔把所有人都从工作中拉走，带到他的迪斯科咖啡馆去。咖啡迪斯科（Cafe Disco）。他的咖啡迪斯科。你会看到凯文在那里手忙脚乱地制作他的浓缩咖啡。这是因为他在等琳。如果你看过所有那些被删减的连贯情节，你就会知道他是在盼望琳出现。事实上，在拍摄剧本中，这场戏要更长一些。
And Kevin tells Michael he's waiting for Lynn. Wow. And Angela enters and this scene when I enter, I could barely get through Jenna. I think you can tell I'm breaking if you watch it because whenever Steve is Michael offers Kevin the fake cookie in his hand, I literally, I start smiling when I talk because I'm having such a hard time not laughing. It's so absurd and wonderful. And a lot of that is Brian Baumgartner's performance.
凯文告诉迈克尔他在等琳。哇。然后安吉拉进来了，当我出场时，詹娜，我几乎快要演不下去了。我想如果你仔细看的话，能看出我笑场了，因为每当史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔把手里那个假饼干递给凯文时，我真的是一说话就会笑出来，因为我太难忍住不笑了。这太荒谬美妙了。这很大程度上要归功于布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳的表演。
Yes. His like immediate belief that there's a cookie in a hand that clearly didn't have a cookie one second ago. Yes. Well, the three of us improvised the whole last couplet of dialogue. No way. Yes. So in the script, I mean, the script was phenomenal, but as we started doing it, Steve, as Michael
是的。他那种立刻相信手里有饼干的反应，而那只手明明一秒钟前还没有饼干。是的。好吧，我们三个人即兴发挥了整段对话的最后几句。不会吧。是的。所以剧本里——我是说，剧本写得太棒了，但当我们开始演的时候，史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔
just kept messing with Kevin, he kept showing him the cookie, but then pulling it a little out of reach. So Kevin had to walk further into the room and that was just stuff we were making up on the day. Well, in the script, it was just a little cleaner of an ending, right? It was a little simpler. It was like, Michael said Kevin stay, Angela said Kevin come, and then Michael's like Kevin cookie.
一直在逗凯文，他一直向凯文展示那个饼干，但随后又把它拿得稍微有点够不着。所以凯文不得不往房间里走得更深一点，这些都是我们当天即兴发挥出来的。好吧，在剧本里，结局要更干净利落一些，对吧？要更简单一点。大概就是，迈克尔说凯文留下，安吉拉说凯文过来，然后迈克尔说“凯文，饼干”。
And then Kevin's like, what? There's a cookie. And then I drag him away. We just had so much fun with this fake cookie. We just improvised this little couplet at the end where Kevin's like, wait, is there a cookie? And Michael's like, mm-hmm. And I'm like, no, for goodness sakes, Kevin, there's no cookie.
然后凯文说，“什么？有饼干。”然后我把他拉走。我们对这个假饼干玩得太开心了。我们在最后即兴发挥了这几句台词，凯文说，“等等，有饼干吗？”迈克尔说，“嗯哼。”我说，“不，看在老天的份上，凯文，根本没有饼干。”
There's no cookie. Come on. And I kind of like show him. I'm trying to pry Michael's hand. And Kevin's like, I wanted a cookie. And then I look back at Michael and I'm like, completely unacceptable. It was so fun. We had a blast.
没有饼干。拜托。我有点像是在给他看。我试图掰开迈克尔的手。凯文说，“我还想要个饼干呢。”然后我回过头看着迈克尔，说道，“简直不可理喻。”太好玩了。我们度过了一段极其欢乐的时光。
And somewhere out there, there's just footage of me laughing every time Kevin looks at Michael's hand and is like, was there a cookie? It's so good. Well now Michael is alone. He really wants people to come. So he is going to blast music through the vent. Yes. And people up in the bullpen can hear it.
在某个地方，肯定还有我每次看到凯文看着迈克尔的手并问“刚才有饼干吗”时都在笑的幕后花絮。太搞笑了。好吧，现在迈克尔孤身一人了。他真的很希望大家来。所以他要通过通风口放音乐了。是的。楼上办公区的员工们都能听到。
And everyone kind of starts, you know, moving and grooving a little bit, so much so that Phyllis decides she's going to go. Yeah, she says to heck with it. But first she's going to stop by Vance Refrigeration to invite Bob, where she runs into Bob's younger, yet sort of look-alike secretary. This is how this character was described in the script. As Phyllis walks in, Bob's busty secretary, Jessica, is coming out of Bob's office and closing the door behind her.
大家开始，你知道的，稍微扭动身体跳起舞来，以至于菲莉丝决定她也要去。对，她决定不管三七二十一了。但她首先要在范斯制冷公司（Vance Refrigeration）停下来，邀请鲍勃，在那里她遇到了鲍勃那个年轻但长相有点像她的女秘书。剧本里对这个角色的描述是这样的。当菲莉丝走进去时，鲍勃波涛汹涌的秘书杰西卡正从鲍勃的办公室出来，并在身后关上门。
She wears a low-cut top. Phyllis looks her up and down. Oh, wow, so it doesn't mention that she's meant to sort of be this younger version of Phyllis. Because they dressed her just like Phyllis dresses. I know, I know. And I felt like even like their little noses were similar in everything. Their hairstyles.
她穿着一件低胸上衣。菲莉丝上下打量了她一番。哦，哇，所以剧本里没提她其实应该算是年轻版的菲莉丝吗？因为他们给她化的妆、穿的衣服跟菲莉丝一模一样。我知道，我知道。我觉得甚至她们的小鼻子在各方面都很像。还有她们的发型。
Yes. She's clearly like what Phyllis would think Bob would want in a younger woman. Yes. Which I thought was such a great casting choice. The woman who played Jessica was Alyssa Preston, and according to her IMDB, this job was her first television credit. Oh, she did so great. Do you remember your first television job?
是的。她显然就是菲莉丝认为鲍勃会喜欢的那种年轻版女性。是的。我觉得这是一个非常棒的选角决定。扮演杰西卡的演员叫阿莉莎·普雷斯顿，根据她的IMDB资料，这份工作是她的第一部电视作品。哦，她演得太棒了。你还记得你的第一份电视工作吗？
Oh, God, I do. I think I was horrible. What was it? What was it? Oh, my very first line on a television show was a TV show called Step by Step. The big stars were Suzanne Summers and Patrick Duffy. Was it a three-camera show? It was a multi-camera show.
哦，天哪，我的确是。我觉得我当时演得太糟糕了。那是怎么回事？那是怎么回事？哦，我在电视剧里的第一句台词是，那是一个叫《一步一个脚印》的电视剧。大明星是苏珊·萨默斯和帕特里克·达菲。那是一个三机位拍摄的节目吗？那是一个多机位节目。
In the episode, they think their daughter has run off to a lope. And I was cast because I was the same height and same hair color as the young girl playing their daughter. And they burst into this wedding chapel like in Vegas or somewhere. They burst in and I'm up there saying my vows. So Suzanne Summers whips me around at the altar and she goes, you're not Dana. And I say, no, I'm Simone and thanks for ruining the best day of my life. Wow.
在这一集里，他们以为女儿私奔去结婚了。我被选中是因为我和扮演他们女儿的那个年轻女孩身高和发色一样。他们像在拉斯维加斯或者什么地方一样，突然闯入这个婚礼小教堂。他们冲进来时，我正站在那儿宣誓。所以苏珊·萨默斯在圣坛前把我猛地转过来，她说，你不是达娜。我说，不，我是西蒙尼，谢谢你毁了我生命中最美好的一天。哇。
Is that crazy that I remember that? And I auditioned for it and it wasn't for like two months later that I shot it. And I said to the director that day, I said, how do you want me to do it? And he said, just like you did in the audition, I couldn't remember how I did it in the audition. Oh, no. And then when I did it, they were like, can you tone it down? Because I guess I was like, but thanks for ruining the best day of my life. Well, that's the worst.
我还记得这些，是不是很疯狂？我去试镜了，大概两个月后才拍的。那天我对导演说，我问，你希望我怎么演？他说，就像你试镜时那样，但我记不清自己试镜时是怎么演的了。哦，不。然后当我演完时，他们说，你能收敛一点吗？因为我猜我当时演得像是“但谢谢你毁了我生命中最美好的一天”。好吧，这太糟糕了。
When you have one or two lines on a show and there's no like entrance ramp to your performance, you just have to deliver this one line exactly right. And you're on this new set with new people and there's all this just adrenaline running through you. And Suzanne Summers. Hi. I've watched her my whole childhood whips me around. Well, I was waiting to do my scene after the director gave me that note in rehearsals.
当你在节目中只有一两句台词，而且你的表演没有前奏铺垫时，你必须把这唯一的一句台词说得恰到好处。你身处一个新的片场，周围都是新面孔，体内涌动着所有的肾上腺素。还有苏珊·萨默斯。嗨。我从小看着她的戏长大，她把我猛地转过来。好吧，导演在排练时给我提了那个意见后，我一直在等著拍我的戏。
I literally was in the wings going, thanks for ruining the best day of my life. Thanks for ruining the best day of my life. Thank you for ruining the best day. That's other problem when you have one line. You way over analyze it. So much. I was horrible. Well, Alyssa Preston was amazing.
我简直站在侧幕边说，谢谢你毁了我生命中最美好的一天。谢谢你毁了我生命中最美好的一天。谢谢你毁了我最美好的日子。当你只有一句台词时，这就是另一个问题。你会过度分析它。分析得太多了。我当时太糟糕了。不过阿莉莎·普雷斯顿太棒了。
She was. Her first TV job, she has gone on to work steadily in television and film. She was in Grey's Anatomy, Modern Family, Jane the Virgin, the movie, Horrible Bosses 2, No Monk, No Law and Order, comedy. She's a comedy gal. Comedy gal. Back to the story at hand, Phyllis has decided to go down and start dancing with Michael while she waits for Bob to join her.
的确如此。她的第一份电视工作，后来她一直在电视和电影界稳定工作。她演过《实习医生格蕾》、《摩登家庭》、《处女情缘》，电影《恶老板2》、《怪阿娜》、《法律与秩序》，喜剧。她是个喜剧达人。喜剧达人。回到正题，菲利斯决定下楼和迈克尔一起跳舞，同时等鲍勃来找她。
Yeah. And she's really getting into it so much so she does kind of this pony move and throws out her back. That gasping sort of bleeped mother effort that she says is not in the shooting draft. Really? Yeah. It says that she lets out a yell, you know, but I think that they had fun with that on the day.
对。而且她跳得非常投入，以至于她做了一种小马步的动作，结果扭伤了背。她发出的那种喘息般的、被消音的“妈的”的感叹并不在拍摄剧本里。真的吗？是的。剧本上说她发出一声大叫，你知道的，但我觉得他们当时拍得很开心。
Can I just say that Phyllis is very good at fake injury? I so believed it. I was worried for her. I know. I mean, she gets her like whole face to turn red and stuff and like everything she does as a person with a back injury was so right on for me. She's great at physical comedy. I've got a side story.
我能说菲利斯假装受伤非常在行吗？我当时深信不疑。我为她担心。我知道。我是说，她让整张脸都变红了什么的，而且她作为一个背部受伤的人所做的一切对我都太真实了。她很擅长肢体喜剧。我有一个插曲。
What? I know we just had one. Uh-oh. I threw out my back once just like Phyllis and it was while I was talking to Christy Brinkley. What? Yeah. Christy Brinkley.
什么？我知道我们刚刚讲了一个。哦，不。我有一次扭伤了背，就像菲利斯一样，那是在我和克里斯蒂·布林克利说话的时候。什么？对。克里斯蒂·布林克利。
How do you throw out your back while talking? Phyllis was dancing. Well, I was backstage. I was doing this game show and Christy Brinkley was in the waiting room. She was going to be a guest on the next version of the game show, you know, the next episode. Sure. I was just so excited, I mean, to maybe meet Christy Brinkley. Did you run up or something?
你怎么能在说话的时候扭到背？菲利斯当时在跳舞。好吧，我在后台。我在录制这个游戏节目，克里斯蒂·布林克利在休息室里。她将成为下一期游戏节目的嘉宾，你知道的，下一集。当然。我当时太兴奋了，我是说，可能会见到克里斯蒂·布林克利。你跑过去了吗？
I threw my arms out in a gesture where I was like, hi, Christy Brinkley. And in throwing, just gesturing my arms open, I threw out my back. It was like a pop. It felt like something popped in my back, but I was trying to hold it together because she smiled and she was talking with me and I don't know if she could see the pain like washing over my eyes and my whole body. And like I said, you know, Phyllis gets all red. I felt hot.
我张开双臂做了一个手势，好像在说，嗨，克里斯蒂·布林克利。就在我挥手、把手臂张开的瞬间，我扭伤了背。就像一声脆响。感觉背里有什么东西裂开了，但我一直在强忍着，因为她在微笑，而且在和我说话，我不知道她是否能看到痛苦掠过我的双眼和全身。就像我说的，你知道的，菲利斯脸都变红了。我觉得很热。
Like I felt that and then it just seized up like I couldn't even move. They brought the medic in. On the game show. Yes. They gave me some ice and some Advil and from there I had to get loaded in a car to go to this movie in Canada with Ben Stiller and Mike White. It was my dream job, my dream job. I'm playing Ben Stiller's wife in a Mike White movie.
就像我感觉到了那种热度，然后背就僵住了，我甚至动弹不得。他们把医护人员叫了进来。在游戏节目上。是的。他们给了我一些冰块和止痛药，从那以后，我不得不被抬上一辆车，去加拿大拍本·斯蒂勒和迈克·怀特的这部电影。这是我的梦想工作，我的梦想工作。我在迈克·怀特的电影里扮演本·斯蒂勒的妻子。
And you couldn't move. I couldn't move. All because you wanted to show Christy Brinkley that I was excited to meet her. Hey. Yes. When I got to the airport, they had to have a wheelchair load me onto the plane. I mean, I really couldn't walk. When I got to Canada, they had a doctor meet me at my hotel.
而你却动不了。我动不了。就因为你想向克里斯蒂·布林克利展示我很兴奋能见到她。嘿。是的。当我到达机场时，他们不得不安排轮椅把我送上飞机。我是说，我真的无法走路。当我到达加拿大时，他们安排了一名医生在我的酒店与我见面。
This is crazy. And the next day it was a driving scene. My character was supposed to drive and I couldn't do it. And I was mortified. I was mortified because of course when everybody was like, how did you throw out your back? And you were like, I just made a hugging gesture. Yeah. I just went, hey.
这太疯狂了。第二天是一场开车戏。我的角色本该开车，但我做不到。我感到十分羞愧。我感到十分羞愧，因为当每个人都问，你是怎么扭伤背的？而你会说，我只是做了一个拥抱的手势。对。我只是去了一下，嘿。
And then I seemed like a Looney Tune, but anyway, you can throw out your back very easily. You can. Just a lot of stories for me today. Okay. Is this what the shower has done to me? Yes. It has opened up my vault of story. It has.
然后我看起来像个疯子，不过话说回来，你确实很容易扭伤背。确实如此。今天我有很多故事。好吧。这就是淋浴对我做的事情吗？是的。它打开了我的故事宝库。确实如此。
Well, I want you guys to notice while Phyllis is being lowered to the ground by Michael, that black pipe on the wall by the shower, yeah, does not have any lights on it, but that will change. Oh. It's not lighted now, but it will be. That's right. Michael calls Dwight down to help him get Phyllis back up into the office. Or is it Philip?
好吧，我想让大家注意，当菲利斯被迈克尔放低到地面时，淋浴间旁边墙上的那个黑色管道，是的，上面没有任何灯，但这将会改变。哦。它现在没亮，但以后会亮的。没错。迈克尔把德怀特叫下来帮他把菲利斯弄回办公室。还是菲利普？
Is it? He gets a text. He goes, you said, you said something happened to Philip. And then he looks at Phyllis and goes, did Philip do this to you? They are hilarious, the two of them. Well, this is going to start a whole runner where Dwight is going to be tasked with taking care of Phyllis in the conference room. They're going to wheel her in there.
是吗？他收到一条短信。他说，你说了，你说了菲利普出了什么事。然后他看着菲利斯说，是菲利普对你做了这个吗？他们两个太搞笑了。好吧，这将引发一系列情节，德怀特将被指派在会议室里照顾菲利斯。他们会把她用轮椅推到那里。
He's going to shut all the curtains. And then there's a huge commotion. He comes out in just his tank top. I love moments like that because we don't know what happened in there, clearly something. Halstead shared that in addition to being tasked with creating a storyline that used the old Michael Scott paper company set, they also needed a storyline that they could cut away to. They needed somewhere to go.
他会拉上所有的窗帘。然后会有一场巨大的骚动。他只穿着背心走了出来。我喜欢这样的时刻，因为我们不知道里面发生了什么，显然发生了一些事。霍尔斯特德分享说，除了被指派创作一个使用旧迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司片场的故事情节外，他们还需要一个可以切镜头过去的故事情节。他们需要一个可以去的地方。
But that story also had to take place at Dunder Mifflin because we did not have the budget to go anywhere. Right. And we only had four days. So this story of Phyllis throwing out her back and Dwight helping her was the solution. And I love how scripts and stories sometimes evolve out of that just necessity. Everyone is concerned about Phyllis. There's like moaning sounds coming from the conference room.
但那个故事也必须发生在邓德米弗林，因为我们没有预算去任何地方。没错。而且我们只有四天时间。所以菲利斯扭伤背和德怀特帮助她的这个故事就是解决方案。我喜欢剧本和故事有时是如何从这种纯粹的必要性中演变出来的。每个人都很关心菲利斯。会议室里传出了呻吟声。
And Angela has a line to Michael where she says, can you please go back to work instead of masterminding these situations where in we hurt ourselves? This line was so hard for me to say. Why? Because I don't speak like that. I don't say stop masterminding situations where in we hurt ourselves. Yeah. But Angela had a very formal way of speaking.
安吉拉对迈克尔有一句台词，她说，你能不能回到工作岗位上去，而不是苦心策划这些让我们自己受伤的情况？这句台词对我说来太难念了。为什么？因为我不那样说话。我不会说“停止苦心策划让我们自己受伤的情况”。是的。但安吉拉有一种非常正式的说话方式。
She did. And it was something that was really important to the writers. They carry it through the whole entire series where she has sort of this clipped formality in her voice. I'm just pointing it out because I had a hard time saying it. To me, a sentence like that is very similar to being a doctor on like a show, but you're not really a doctor. Right.
她确实有。这对编剧来说是一件非常重要的事情。他们在整部剧里都贯穿着这一点，她的声音里有一种这种简练的正式感。我只是指出来，因为我很难说出口。对我来说，这样的句子非常类似于在节目里扮演医生，但你并不是真正的医生。没错。
And you have to say medical jargon. I'd never make it. Grey's Anatomy? I'd never be able to do it. No. No, I can't do it. Can't do it. Well, somehow Aaron and Kelly are going to wind up down in Cafe Disco.
而且你必须说医学术语。我绝对不行。《实习医生格蕾》？我永远也做不到。不。不，我做不到。做不到。好吧，不知怎么的，艾伦和凯利最后会来到迪斯科咖啡馆。
Aaron presses play on some music and the ladies start dancing. Yeah. Do you know what this song was? Was it Boyfriend Hangover? Yeah. It's called Boy Hangover. Boy Hangover. Do you know who wrote it?
艾伦按下了一首音乐的播放键，女士们开始跳舞。对。你知道这首歌是什么吗？是《男孩宿醉》吗？对。它叫《男孩宿醉》。男孩宿醉。你知道是谁写的吗？
No. Our writer, Lester Lewis. You are kidding me. No. I thought it was so catchy. It's sung by this woman named Bonnie McKee. She's a Grammy nominated singer-songwriter. She has written number one hits for Britney Spears, Katy Perry, and Tau Cruz.
不。我们的编剧，莱斯特·刘易斯。你在跟我开玩笑吧。没有。我觉得这歌太抓耳了。它是由一个叫邦尼·麦基的女人演唱的。她是一位获得格莱美奖提名的创作型歌手。她为布兰妮·斯皮尔斯、凯蒂·佩里和陶·克鲁斯写过冠军单曲。
I thought we should listen to it. Here's Boy Hangover. How great is it that Lester wrote the lyrics to that song? It's so good. I loved the song. I thought it was catchy. I downloaded it and now I have it. This was one of the songs I was listening to because I like to stay on theme while working
我想我们应该听一下。这就是《男孩宿醉》。莱斯特为这首歌写了歌词，这有多棒？太棒了。我很喜欢这首歌。我觉得它很抓耳。我下载了它，现在我有了这首歌。这是我一直在听的歌之一，因为我喜欢在工作时保持主题一致
on an episode. Yeah. Well, maybe we should take a break. I want to go eat my yogurt. It's been on my mind. Honey, I know it. If you are okay with that. I know it.
在某一集里。好吧，也许我们该休息一下。我想去吃我的酸奶。我一直惦记着呢。亲爱的，我知道。如果你觉得可以的话。我知道。
I saw you eyeing your snack bag. I know. It's time. It's time. We'll be back after I eat my yogurt. Okay. We'll be back. My yogurt was great.
我看见你一直在瞅你的零食袋。我知道。是时候了。是时候了。等我吃完酸奶我们就回来。好的。我们会回来的。我的酸奶太棒了。
Yay. And speaking of eating, Michael is eating his lunch alone. Might as well be dinner. That broke my heart. I know. So sad. Michael. Meanwhile, Phyllis is in the conference room.
太棒了。说到吃，迈克尔正在独自吃午饭。这简直可以当晚饭了。这让我心碎。我知道。太伤心了。迈克尔。与此同时，菲利斯在会议室里。
Dwight has started working on her back and Jim is outside collecting flowers. Yeah. It's very sweet. He's making a little bouquet for Pam. Jenna, this is on the side of the writer's building where the warehouse was. So automatically, I was like, is this 3.30 p.m.? Yes. Because we learned last week we filmed there at 3.30.
德怀特开始帮她按摩背部，吉姆则在外面收集花朵。是的。非常甜蜜。他正在为帕姆做一个小花束。珍娜，这是编剧大楼靠近仓库的那一侧。所以我自然会想，这是下午3点30分吗？是的。因为我们上周了解到我们是在3点30分在那儿拍摄的。
Also, you know those flowers weren't there. No. They had planted them just for the scene so that he could then cut them. There have never been flowers there. Just some weeds, kind of. Yeah. And a giant bug. But that's it.
还有，你知道那些花本来是不在那里的。不。那是为了这场戏特意种上的，这样他才能把它们剪下来。那里从来没有过花。只有一些杂草。是的。还有一个巨大的虫子。但仅此而已。
Yeah. We had a big bunch of parrots that we had for a small period of time. And that one rooster across the way. But not flowers. But not flowers. So they would plant and then replant these flowers so that Jim could collect them. So those were some fakie real flowers. Meanwhile, Cafe Disco is popping.
是的。我们有一大群鹦鹉，只待了一小段时间。还有对面那只公鸡。但没有花。但没有花。所以他们会种植然后重新种植这些花，以便吉姆可以收集它们。所以那些是一些假的真花。与此同时，迪斯科咖啡馆正人头攒动。
Aaron has invited a friend, Ashley. I loved the exchange between Oscar and Aaron when he's like, what, you invited someone? And Aaron's like, yeah, is that not okay? And Oscar's like, I mean, I've worked here eight years and I never. And then they just run off and he goes, rude. I just loved it. Ashley doesn't have any lines, but she was played by Alexis Teague and now begins what looks like a dance-off between Kelly and Andy.
艾伦邀请了一位朋友阿什利。我很喜欢奥斯卡和艾伦之间的对话，当奥斯卡说，什么，你邀请了别人？艾伦说，对啊，这有什么不可以吗？奥斯卡说，我的意思是，我在这里工作了八年，我从来没有。然后他们跑开，奥斯卡说，真粗鲁。我太喜欢这段了。阿什利没有台词，但她由亚历克斯·蒂格饰演，现在开始了一场看起来像是凯利和安迪之间的斗舞。
We had a fan question from Geanna W. The dance-off runner between Andy and Kelly is so great. I personally think they would have made a good couple. Did the writers ever think of doing that? So I asked Warren about this and he said, the writer's room pretty much discussed every possible dating scenario for Kelly. But Andy and Kelly never made it on one of those note cards and he said, you know what? That would have been great.
我们有一个来自吉娜·W的粉丝提问。安迪和凯利之间的斗舞真是太棒了。我个人认为他们会成为绝配。编剧们有没有想过让他们在一起？所以我问了沃伦关于这事，他说，编剧室几乎讨论了凯利所有可能的约会场景。但安迪和凯利从未进入过那些便签卡，他说，你知道吗？那一定很棒。
I wish we would have gone there. I thought they had great chemistry. I did too. They seem great for each other. And I would like you to note at 13 minutes 54 seconds at the beginning of the dance-off, red chili pepper lights on the black pipe by the shower. Where did those come from? I don't know.
我希望我们当时能那样做。我觉得他们很有化学反应。我也这么觉得。他们看起来天造地设。我想请大家注意在13分54秒，斗舞开始的时候，淋浴喷头旁边的黑管子上有红辣椒灯。那些是从哪里来的？我不知道。
Did Aaron and Kelly like start decorating when they went down there? Did Ashley bring them? No, Ashley didn't bring them. Were they there? They were there. Oh yeah, Ashley just got there. They weren't there when Phyllis was dancing, but now they're there for the dance-off. And Michael is missing all of it.
是艾伦和凯利下去时开始装饰的吗？是阿什利带来的吗？不，阿什利没带来。它们本来就在那儿吗？它们就在那儿。哦，对，阿什利刚到那儿。菲利斯跳舞时它们不在，但现在斗舞时它们就在了。而迈克尔错过了这一切。
He's up in the kitchen being a sad sack. But he can hear it. He says, I can still hear the music in my head. Well, Creed is going to exit the bathroom. The men's room. While eating chicken, I really love that detail. Halstead mentioned it was one of the little jokes that he loved as well. He's full on eating a chicken leg.
他在厨房里当个闷油瓶。但他能听到。他说，我脑子里还能听到音乐。好吧，克里德从洗手间出来了。男洗手间。一边吃鸡肉，我真的很喜欢这个细节。霍尔斯特德提到这也是他非常喜欢的小笑话之一。他正在大口吃鸡腿。
Yeah. Coming out of the restroom. And Creed's like, I hear it too, Michael. Creed says, I hear it too, boss. Oh yeah, I hear it too, boss. So Michael's like, oh my gosh, something's happening. And sure enough, he gets down to the cafe disco and it's like happening. It's a party.
是的。从洗手间出来。克里德说，我也听到了，迈克尔。克里德说，我也听到了，老板。哦，对，我也听到了，老板。所以迈克尔就像，哦天哪，有情况了。果不其然，他来到迪斯科咖啡馆，发现确实在进行。这是一个派对。
There's a limbo pole. Yeah. And I have questions. Okay. Because it's so great. You see two people walk in and they have to like, you know, limbo under. Meredith does a shimmy. Your character walks in and just walks under it.
有一根林 limbo（过杆）杆。是的。我有一些问题。好的。因为太棒了。你看到两个人走进来，他们必须，你知道，从杆子底下钻过去。梅雷迪思扭动着身子。你的角色走进来，直接从下面走过去了。
Just straight under it. No problem. Didn't have to bend at all. Who wrote that joke? Well, I asked Warren and Halstead and they both were like, it was Warren. Warren was like, yeah, that was me. Well, it's hilarious to me, this is my ex-husband's joke because he clearly knows I'm a short stack.
径直走过去。毫无问题。根本不用弯腰。是谁写的这个笑话？好吧，我问了沃伦和霍尔斯特德，他们都说，是沃伦。沃伦说，对，那是我写的。好吧，我觉得这太搞笑拉，这是我前夫写的笑话，因为他显然知道我是个矮个子。
Well, how did you do it? Did they bring you down and measure you to set the pole? Oh yeah. They duct taped that pole to the wall, right, that everyone walked under. It's like a broom. It's meant to look like a broom handle, right? And I had to practice walking under it. I on purpose this episode, I wear flats.
好吧，你是怎么做到的？他们把你叫下来量身高来设置杆子吗？哦，是的。他们用胶带把那根杆子粘在墙上，对吧，每个人都从下面走过。这就像一把扫帚。它看起来像一把扫帚柄，对吧？我不得不练习从下面走过。这一集我故意穿了平底鞋。
My character never wears flats. My character is always in three inch heels. This entire episode I had on little tiny flats. Wow. This is the shoe thing you were mentioning earlier. Yes. I'll put it in stories. I took a screen grab of them and I did ever so slightly guys have to tilt my head just
我的角色从不穿平底鞋。我的角色总是穿着三英寸的高跟鞋。整整这一集我都穿着小小的平底鞋。哇。这就是你刚才提到的鞋子的事。是的。我会把它发到故事里。我截了它们的图，而且我确实不得不微微地把头倾斜一下……
very tiny, but I could walk right under that pole. It was so funny. I'm the person, guys, when your plane lands and everyone stands up and they're waiting and everyone has to duck because the overhead compartments, you know, when you are still at your seat, you haven't been able to get in the aisle because there's so many people getting their stuff. I can stand fully upright under the overhead. That must feel so good.
非常小的一点，但我可以直接从那个杆子底下走过去。太搞笑了。伙计们，我就是那种人在你们的飞机降落时每个人都站起来等待，每个人都得低头因为行李舱，你知道的，当你还在座位上时，你还没法走到过道里，因为有太多人在拿他们的东西。我可以在行李舱下面站得笔直。那感觉一定太棒了。
Yeah. I just look at all these people hunched over while they're waiting to get off a plane. I got no problem. But don't ask you to get something off the top shelf. No. Why would I put anything on the top shelf? You don't. The only reason Angela is there is to get some signatures on a piece of paper and Michael
是的。我看着所有这些人在等待下飞机时弓着身子。我一点问题都没有。但别叫我去拿顶层的的东西。不。我怎么会把任何东西放在顶层呢？你不会。安吉拉在那里的唯一原因就是为了在一张纸上拿到签名，而迈克尔
says he's only going to give her one signature per song. And Angela, you have this line where you say, I don't like the general spirit of music. My character says, look, I hate to be that person, but I just don't like the general spirit of music. Renee from Fargo, North Dakota would like to know who wrote that line. She loves it. So we asked Warren and Halstead this question and Warren said it's probably his favorite question because he loves that line too.
说他一首歌只给她签一个名。而安吉拉，你有这样一句台词，你说，我不喜欢音乐的整体精神。我的角色说，听着，我讨厌成为那种人，但我就是不喜欢音乐的精神。来自北达科他州法尔戈的蕾妮想知道是谁写的这句台词。她很喜欢。所以我们向沃伦和霍尔斯特德提出了这个问题，沃伦说这可能是他最喜欢的问题，因为他也非常喜欢那句台词。
He shared that he and Halstead were writing together on a short-lived show for the WB called Modern Men, starring Jane Seymour and Max Greenfield. And in one of the episodes, one of the guys is trying to break up with his drab girlfriend played by guest actor, Arden Mirren. Oh, I love her. She's hilarious. She's so funny. Warren said she was amazingly funny.
他分享说，他和霍尔斯特德曾一起在华纳兄弟电视台（WB）的一部短命电视剧中合作编剧，剧名叫《摩登硬汉》，由简·西摩和马克斯·格林菲尔德主演。在其中一集里，其中一个男人试图和他的呆板女友分手，女友由客串演员阿登·米伦饰演。哦，我爱死她了。她太滑稽了。她太搞笑了。沃伦说她滑稽得惊人。
And Halstead and Warren had pitched a line that she hates music. And what Arden's character said was, not a fan, like about music. And they said that Arden killed it and it was really funny. And when they went to write this episode, they really could see Angela identifying with that and they borrowed their own line and added a little tweak. I think it is such an amazing character trait for a person to just be like, I don't get music. Yeah, I'm not a fan.
霍尔斯特德和沃伦曾提出过一个台词，说她讨厌音乐。而阿登的角色所说的是，不是粉丝，就像是针对音乐说的。他们说阿登把这个角色演绝了，真的非常搞笑。当他们着手写这一集时，他们真的能看出安吉拉与此产生共鸣，于是他们借用了他们自己的台词并做了一些小调整。我认为对于一个人来说，这真是一个绝妙的角色特质，就是那种“我不懂音乐”。是的，我不是粉丝。
I'm not a big music person myself. I know this about you, Jenna, because when we went on our writer's retreat, you were very concentrated on our meal plan. What were we going to be eating? Yes. And I said something like, what about a playlist for the car ride? And you're like, yeah, I don't care. I don't know if this is why, but the car that I drove out to LA, it had no air conditioning,
我自己也不是一个狂热的音乐爱好者。我知道你这点，珍娜，因为当我们去参加我们的编剧静修时，你非常专注于我们的膳食计划。我们要吃什么？是的。我说过类似的话，车程放个播放列表怎么样？然后你说，好吧，我不在乎。我不知道这是否是原因，但我开到洛杉矶的那辆车，没有空调，
and no working radio. Oh my gosh, you were driving in a car with no music on a road trip? Yeah. And I also had this car in college and my college was three hours from my hometown. And so I would often drive very, very, very long distances in silence or I sometimes did bring like an old fashioned cassette player and hit play. I hope. And I could play off of that, but I got really conditioned to driving without sound.
也没有好用的收音机。哦天哪，你在公路旅行中开着一辆没有音乐的车？是的。我在大学里也有这辆车，我的大学离我的家乡有三个小时的路程。所以我经常在安静中驾驶非常非常非常长的距离，或者有时我会带一台老式盒式磁带机并按下播放键。我希望。我可以据此播放，但我对在没有声音的情况下开车真的很适应。
And now I listen to news or podcasts, but I just never kind of got into playlists or music. Oh my gosh. I find it like, I don't know. I do like music. Like I have whole albums. I have sounds of Scranton, you know, like I use music a lot when I'm formulating a character, which is so interesting because if you had to formulate the character of Jenna Fisher,
现在我听新闻或播客，但我只是从来没有真正迷上播放列表或音乐。哦天哪。我觉得它，我不知道。我确实喜欢音乐。就像我有整张专辑。我有斯克兰顿之声，你知道的，比如我在塑造角色时经常使用音乐，这太有趣了，因为如果你必须塑造珍娜·费舍尔这个角色，
you would have no music, you'd have no music, but good food. Yeah. I mean, I love a combo. I love, I love a playlist for a road trip, but then I like to turn it off and talk, you know, because I'm chatty. My mom always says the best place to talk is in the car. That's why I love to do school pick up and drop off. I feel like my kids are super chatty.
你不会有音乐，你不会有音乐，但有好吃的。是的。我的意思是，我喜欢组合。我喜欢，我喜欢公路旅行的播放列表，但随后我喜欢关掉它然后聊天，你知道的，因为我很健谈。我妈妈总是说最好的聊天地方是在车里。这就是为什么我喜欢接送孩子上下学。我觉得我的孩子们超级健谈。
Yeah. Talking about their day. Right after school. Yeah. My dad loves a playlist and he makes a playlist for every road trip we take and it's really cute because the kids now are so connected to it. So we were listening a lot to the red hot chili peppers when we went up to the mountains in Big Bear and Jack will say whenever they come on now, he's like, that's Big Bear.
对。聊聊他们的一天。放学后马上。对。我爸爸非常喜欢播放列表，他给我们每次的公路旅行都制作一个播放列表，这真的很可爱，因为现在的孩子们和它联系太紧密了。所以当我们去大熊湖的山上时，我们听了很多红辣椒乐队的歌，现在只要他们的歌一放出来，杰克就会说，那是大熊湖。
You know, my kids and Lee are very connected to music and they do the same thing and we have those same things. Like Vampire Weekend for us was like the summer of 2019. That's Vampire Weekend. White Stripes, Seven Nation Army. Love it. They would listen to that song as we were driving up to go skiing in Santa Fe. Oh, yeah.
你知道的，我的孩子们和李对音乐都很有感觉，他们也做同样的事情，我们也有这些共同的爱好。比如吸血鬼周末乐队对我们来说就像2019年的夏天。那是吸血鬼周末乐队。白色条纹乐队的《七国军团》。太喜欢了。当我们在开车去圣达菲滑雪的路上时，他们就会听那首歌。哦，对。
So whenever I hear that song, I just feel the snowy mountain. I'm going to Wichita. Yeah. It's so good. So good. Oh, can I take us into the conference room with Dwight and Phyllis where he's treating her like livestock and he's rubbing otter oil into her back. Yeah.
所以每当我听到那首歌，我就会感受到白雪皑皑的山峰。我要去威奇托。对。太棒了。太棒了。哦，能把我们带进德怀特和菲利斯的会议室吗？他在那里把她当成牲口对待，正把海狸香抹在她的背上。对。
I'm giving her a carrot. I thought for sure this otter oil thing was made up. Is it real? Lady otter glands can be purchased. Oh, how do they get them? Well from dead otters. They take their anal glands. Oh Lord.
我正给她一根胡萝卜。我原以为这个海狸香的事情是编出来的。这是真的吗？雌海狸的腺体是可以买到的。哦，他们是怎么弄到这些的？嗯，从死海狸身上。他们取下它们的肛门腺。哦天哪。
And they grind them up and they age them and then they preserve them. Who thought of that? Who thought of is like, save that otter's ass. I don't know. There's some stuff in there I need to grind up. You can get one ounce for about eight bucks on another website. I saw you could get it for six. So if you're in the market, shop around.
然后把它们磨碎，陈化，接着保存起来。谁想出这个的？谁会想出这种主意，就像是，保存那个海狸的屁股。我不知道。里面有些东西我需要磨碎。你可以在另一个网站上花大约八美元买到一盎司。我看到你可以六美元买到。所以如果你有需要，可以到处逛逛比比价。
Then what do people use it for? That's what I wanted to know. I guess you use it to lure an otter. Which made me wonder. You lure an otter with their own anal glands crushed up. Yeah. With the scent of their own anal glands. Why?
那人们用它来做什么呢？这就是我想知道的。我猜你是用它来引诱海狸的。这让我很好奇。你用它们自己的被碾碎的肛门腺来引诱海狸。对。用它们自己的肛门腺的气味。为什么？
Exactly. Why am I luring an otter? I guess hunting. But it's just for sport because you don't really use them for anything. You don't use their fur or you don't eat them. You just, I guess, sprinkle their anal glands and then kill them. Why? This is horrible.
完全正确。我为什么要引诱海狸？我猜是打猎。但这只是为了好玩，因为你并不是真的用它们来做什么。你不用它们的皮毛，也不吃它们。我猜你只是撒上它们的肛门腺，然后杀了它们。为什么？这太可怕了。
Well, there's a whole market for this sort of like- Surely there's something we don't know. I don't know. But there's like a lot of gland. You can buy a lot of glands of different animals for this purpose of luring them. So basically these animals smell their own. And I guess they think it's another otter and they come out to say hi. Terrible.
嗯，这类的市场很大——肯定有什么是我们不知道的。我不知道。但有很多腺体。你可以买到许多不同动物的腺体，目的就是为了引诱它们。所以基本上这些动物闻到了它们自己的味道。然后我猜它们以为那是另一只海狸，就会出来打招呼。太糟糕了。
This is like Bambi all over again for me. I know. And no references to rubbing it into someone's back for an injury. I just want to say if Phyllis went out to the woods, she would be very popular. It would be like a snow white moment for her. She would have a lot of otters coming to say hi. So Dwight and the Shroots could kill them. I guess so.
对我来说，这简直就是又一次《小鹿斑比》。我知道。而且没有提到把它揉进别人的背部来治疗受伤。我只想说，如果菲利斯走到树林里，她会非常受欢迎。对她来说就像是一个白雪公主的时刻。会有很多海狸出来跟她打招呼。然后德怀特和施鲁特家族就可以杀死它们。我想是的。
But that is some information I found. I am confused by all of that information, but thank you for sharing it. You're welcome. Okay. There is a full-on dance competition happening now. There sure is. And we got mail from Alexis W. in Australia who said, I have to know if the dance competition between Andy and Kelly was freestyle or scripted.
但这就是我找到的一些信息。我对所有这些信息感到困惑，但谢谢你分享。不客气。好的。现在正在进行一场全面的舞蹈比赛。确实如此。我们收到了来自澳大利亚的亚历克西斯·W的来信，她说，我必须知道安迪和凯莉之间的舞蹈比赛是自由发挥还是照剧本演的。
Lady, I went to the script. And guess what? It is fully scripted. I'm going to read you the descriptions. Here is Andy's dance-off description of the script. Andy takes a chair and hops over the back of it, turns around, does a Fred Astaire walk over it so that the chair's back falls to the ground. He picks it up, sits on it, and spins on it in a Bob Fosse fashion flashing jazz hands.
亲爱的，我看了剧本。你猜怎么着？完全是按剧本演的。我来给你们读一下描述。以下是剧本中对安迪舞蹈对决的描述。安迪拿了一把椅子，从椅背上跳过去，转过身，用弗雷德·阿斯泰尔的步态走过去，把椅背弄倒在地上。他把它捡起来，坐在上面，像鲍勃·福斯那样旋转，闪现着爵士舞的手势。
He then throws one leg over the back of the chair, gets up, picks up the chair, and pretends that the chair is attacking him and then pretends to be killed by the chair. He gets up and eyes Kelly like try to top that. Kelly's description is this. Kelly walks over to the shower area. She pretends to turn on the shower and mimes getting wet and lathering herself with soap. Oh my. She then walks to the chair, which is next to where Andy stands.
然后他把一条腿扔过椅背，站起来，拿起椅子，假装椅子在攻击他，然后假装被椅子杀死。他站起来，看着凯莉，眼神仿佛在说“有本事超越这个”。凯莉的描述是这样的。凯莉走到淋浴区。她假装打开淋浴喷头，做出身上淋湿并用肥皂擦洗的动作。天哪。然后她走向椅子，椅子就在安迪站的地方旁边。
She stops at the chair, turns like a runway model, winks at Andy, picks up the chair, and walks back to the shower area with it. She sits down, arches her back, a la flash dance, and pretends to be drenched by the shower. She whips her hair around her head in a frenzy. And Kelly starts krunking. Okay. That's a dance move.
她在椅子旁停下，像T台模特一样转身，向安迪抛了个媚眼，拿起椅子，拿着它走回淋浴区。她坐下来，像《闪舞》那样拱起后背，假装被淋浴冲得湿透。她疯狂地在头周围甩动头发。然后凯莉开始跳电臀舞。好吧。那是个舞蹈动作。
She's putting all her best stuff out there. She is. Well, you might notice that the way it is described is not exactly how you end up seeing it in the show. And that is because Randy did hire a choreographer, and the choreographer's job was to interpret the script and then work with the actors to come up with their moves. Randy said our choreographer's name was Mary Ann Kellogg, and she came to us via recommendation from our first AD, Kelly Cantley.
她把她最好的东西都拿出来了。她确实拿出来了。嗯，你可能会注意到，它的描述方式并不完全是你最后在节目中看到的那个样子。那是因为兰迪确实雇了一位编舞，编舞的工作就是诠释剧本，然后与演员合作设计出他们的动作。兰迪说我们的编舞叫玛丽安·凯洛格，她是经由我们的第一助理导演凯莉·坎特利推荐给我们的。
Randy said she was absolutely superb and really got this scene. And Warren said they had to use a good choreographer because if the actors had just freestyled the whole time, it would have been impossible to edit. So although Mindy and Ed brought a lot of ideas for what they would do, this was a planned out dance off. Yeah. Kind of bass loosely on the script, it seems, but it morphed. It evolved in this rehearsal process.
兰迪说她绝对是一流的，而且真的懂这场戏。沃伦说他们必须请一个好的编舞，因为如果演员们全程都自由发挥，剪辑就会变得不可能。因此，尽管明迪和埃德为他们要做的事情提出了很多想法，但这这是一场精心策划的舞蹈对决。对。看起来有点松散地以剧本为基础，但它改变了。它在排练过程中演变了。
And Halstead said he definitely remembers them pitching that flash dance moment, and that made it in. You know, something else that Randy shared with us was that we were not listening to music during this. They were using what's called a thump track. Again, for editing purposes, they would just have this speaker that would play the sort of baseline beat of the song so that the actors would be on tempo. But for editing purposes, they put the song on later.
霍尔斯特德说他绝对记得他们提出了那个《闪舞》的时刻，而且那个时刻被保留进去了。你知道，兰迪和我们分享的另一件事是，我们在跳这个时并没有听音乐。他们使用的是所谓的“重击音轨”。同样是为了剪辑的目的，他们只会让这个扬声器播放歌曲的低音节奏，这样演员们就能踩准拍子。但为了剪辑，他们后来才把歌曲放进去。
I know. So these guys are doing this whole thing. You were there. Was it so crazy? It was so crazy. And also, this is not about the dance off, but I could always really tell when there was no music when Ellie was dancing because Ellie just kind of does these jabs and kind of runs in place, like not at all to what the beat of the song was that's playing.
我知道。所以这些人正在做这一切。你在现场。是不是太疯狂了？太疯狂了。而且，这跟舞蹈对决无关，但我总能清楚地看出艾莉跳舞时什么时候没有音乐，因为艾莉总是做那种刺拳动作，然后有点像在原地跑步，完全跟正在播放的歌曲节拍对不上。
But there was one little moment in the background. I start to tidy up. Yes. And Michael tells Angela to stop. And this cracked me up, Jenna, because I do this in real life. I often at a party at a total stranger's house will start stacking plates, busing dirty cups, putting napkins in the trash bin. Well, this is where we're similar because I do the same thing.
但在背景里有一个小小的时刻。我开始收拾屋子。是的。迈克尔叫安吉拉停下。这让我大笑，詹娜，因为我在现实生活中也这样做。我经常在完全陌生的人家里的聚会上开始叠盘子，收拾脏杯子，把餐巾纸扔进垃圾桶。嗯，这就是我们相似的地方，因为我也做同样的事情。
Someone did that to me once. I had thrown a party and one of the moms went around and was tidying kind of near the end. And I was like, oh my gosh, that just took up like 25% of the cleaning. And it was such a nice gesture. So now I like to do it too. When I leave a party, I'll first do a sweep. I get rid of all the empty cans and glasses and stack the plastic cups. Yes.
有一次有人对我也这么做过。我举办了一个聚会，其中一位妈妈四处走动，在快结束时顺便收拾了一下。当时我就想，哦天哪，这简直承担了大约25%的清洁工作。这是一个非常贴心的举动。所以现在我也喜欢这么做了。当我离开聚会时，我会先扫视一遍。我清理掉所有的空罐子和玻璃杯，把塑料杯叠起来。对。
Yes. Put stuff by the sink. I know. I related to Angela in that moment, but I love how she's like, am I not supposed to have any fun? Yes, because tidying is fun for her. We should probably check back in on Phyllis. Yeah.
对。把东西放在水槽旁。我知道。那一刻我对安吉拉感同身受，但我喜欢她那种“难道我连一点乐趣都不能有吗”的表情。对，因为收拾屋子对她来说就是乐趣。我们可能应该去看看菲利斯怎么样了。对。
Dwight is still trying to work out this kink in her back and then Phyllis just blurts out. I think Bob's going to cheat on me with his new secretary. And then she starts laughing. And then her back is better. Yeah. And Dwight's like, why are you laughing? And she said, oh, just saying it out loud. It just sounds so ridiculous.
德怀特仍在努力治好她背上的那个肌肉痉挛，接着菲利斯突然脱口而出。我觉得鲍勃要跟他的新秘书出轨了。然后她开始大笑。接着她的背就好了。对。德怀特一脸茫然地说，你笑什么？她说，哦，只是说出来了。听起来太荒谬了。
And she was able to let all that tension and stress go. We had a fan question from Liz B. in Columbus, Ohio. She said, in this episode, Phyllis mentions that Bob might be having an affair, but then no one mentions it again. Was there more to this storyline that got deleted, either from this episode or future episodes? No. We asked Warren and Halstead about this, and they told us that their idea here was just
她得以释放所有的紧张和压力。我们收到了来自俄亥俄州哥伦布市的莉兹·B的一个粉丝提问。她说，在这集里，菲利斯提到鲍勃可能有了外遇，但后来没有人再提起了。这个故事情节还有更多被删减的内容吗，无论是从这一集还是从以后的剧集里？没有。我们问过沃伦和霍尔斯特德关于这个的问题，他们告诉我们，他们的想法其实很简单
that the cause of her back pain was the stress. And they thought it was a funny way to end this storyline of Dwight trying to heal her. Like, Dwight's treatments weren't the cure, and the dancing wasn't even the problem. Right. Like, she was going to throw her back out anyway from just holding on to this little stress, and then she cured herself. And then Dwight had to staple her blouse back together. He did.
就是她背痛的原因正是压力。他们觉得这是结束德怀特试图治疗她的这个故事情节的一种有趣方式。比如，德怀特的治疗并不是解药，跳舞甚至也不是问题所在。对。就像她无论如何都会因为仅仅背负着这点小压力而扭伤背部，然后她自己把自己治好了。接着德怀特不得不把她的衬衫重新订在一起。他确实这么做了。
So now we're about to see Jim and Pam. And Pam's going to come out of the bathroom. So cute. She looked so sweet, Jenna, in your pink dress and your hair up. I have to say something, though. What? Did you notice throughout the whole beginning of this episode that I had this pink dress on underneath my sweater?
所以现在我们要看到吉姆和帕姆了。帕姆要从洗手间出来了。太可爱了。詹娜，你穿着粉红色的裙子，盘着头发，看起来太甜美了。不过我得说点什么。什么？你有没有注意到在这一集的整个开头部分，我的毛衣里面都穿着这件粉红色的裙子？
Well, it looked like a pink sweater with a pink skirt, so I thought it was a good, fakey sale. But then that tells me you wore the dress the whole day. Why? Yeah. But why did— She went and did her hair all different and put flowers in her hair. Why couldn't she just bring her dress to work?
嗯，它看起来像是一件粉红色的毛衣配了一条粉红色的裙子，所以我以为这是一个很好的、假装的搭配。但这就告诉我你一整天都穿着这条裙子。为什么？对。但为什么——她去把头发弄成了各种不同的发型，还在头发里插了花。为什么她就不能把裙子带到公司去换呢？
I know. But also, why did she drive to New York to start art school in a pencil skirt? I don't know. Pam's a mystery when she comes to some of her wardrobe choices. She really is. She really, really is. I feel like people in the office would have clocked this strange, poofy, bubble skirt coming out of her bottom half.
我知道。而且，为什么她穿着铅笔裙开车去纽约开始上艺术学校？我不知道。帕姆在某些服装选择上真是一个谜。她真的是。她真的是、真的是。我觉得办公室里的人应该早就注意到她下半身穿着这件奇怪的、蓬松的泡泡裙了。
I clocked it in the very first scene. I was sitting in my chair, and I was like, what is that? You know what I thought it was? I thought I had a blanket. Blanket. Because you were cold. Yes. And I was like, oh my gosh, they caught my blanket.
我在第一场戏里就注意到了。我当时坐在椅子上，心想，那是什么？你知道我当时以为那是什么吗？我以为我拿了一条毯子。毯子。因为你觉得冷。对。当时我就想，哦天哪，他们拍到我的毯子了。
And I was going to do a blanket catch, proof of cold. I was like, oh no, that's my wardrobe. Well, as they're walking out of the office, they hear the music playing, and they're like, I think we should pop in. We should go just for a minute before we head to the courthouse. I think Jim says it would mean so much to him. Mm-hmm. Michael is thrilled.
我本来打算做一个接毯子的动作，证明我很冷。我想，哦不，那是我的戏服。好吧，当他们走出办公室时，他们听到音乐在播放，然后他们就想，我想我们应该进去看看。在我们去法院之前，我们应该去待一会儿。我想吉姆说这对意义重大。嗯-hmm。迈克尔欣喜若狂。
Oh my gosh, he's so happy the whole gang is there. And now everyone is dancing, I mean, except Angela. And Kevin and Lynn, who are making out. Full on make out, which is the end of the Kevin Bacon's runner. We got some mail about the dancing here. We're dancing to YMCA. Monica A. and Jennifer P. said, were Jim's dorky dance moves choreographed, or is that John Krasinski's own true style?
哦天哪，全班人马都在这儿，他高兴极了。现在大家都在跳舞，我是说，除了安吉拉。还有凯文和琳，他们正在热吻。完全是法式热吻，这也是凯文·贝肯梗的结局。我们收到了一些关于这里跳舞的信。我们在跳YMCA。莫妮卡·A和詹妮弗·P说，吉姆那些滑稽的舞步是编排好的，还是约翰·卡拉辛斯基自己的真实风格？
I don't think your dance moves were choreographed in the background. Sarah Lassen89 said, please address the fact that John Krasinski seems to only have one dance move jumping up and down. He does the same thing in the lip dub cold open of nepotism. Oh my gosh. I will tell you, John and I met with the choreographer. Did you really? We did.
我觉得你们在背景里的舞步不是排练好的。萨拉·拉森89说，请指出这样一个事实：约翰·卡拉辛斯基似乎只有一种舞步——上蹿下跳。他在《裙带关系》的对口型开场里也做了同样的动作。哦天哪。我告诉你，我和约翰跟编舞见面了。真的吗？我们见过了。
Because we had this discussion, like, what is Jim and Pam's dancing gonna be when they get there? And also they say they like cheesy, so what does that mean? Well, we had all these conversations and one of them was, is there any reason why Jim and Pam might be slow dancing to YMCA, where they're making kind of a wedding moment out of it? We discussed, we were like, I don't think so. I think we need to lean into the kind of like they like cheesy, you know.
因为我们讨论过这个问题，比如吉姆和帕姆到那儿之后会跳什么舞？而且他们还说他们喜欢老土的，那意味着什么呢？好吧，我们进行了所有这些讨论，其中一个就是，吉姆和帕姆有没有什么理由会对照着YMCA跳慢舞，把这跳成一个类似婚礼仪式的时刻？我们讨论过，我们觉得，不，我觉得不需要。我觉得我们需要倾向于那种他们喜欢老套的东西，你知道的。
It's part of the reason they want a big wedding, so they can be dorky with their friends on the dance floor. Yes. And so the choreographer just was like, well, let's see how you two would do it. I'll just remember, I feel like you could hear a pin drop. We're like, okay. I mean, that's really pretty much just us. That's just, that's what I thought.
这也是他们想要一个盛大婚礼的部分原因，这样他们就能在舞池里和朋友们一起表现得很滑稽。对。所以编舞就说，好吧，看看你们俩会怎么跳。我只记得，我觉得当时安静得连根针掉在地上都能听见。我们说，好吧。我的意思是，这真的基本上就是我们自己。那就是，那就是我所想的。
Me and John just, I was shocked when you said you met with a choreographer. But they liked it, and so the choreographer was like, yeah, just do that. That's good. Perfect. That's good. Maybe she was like, I don't even know where to begin, so just do what you're doing. Well I'll say, I loved shooting these dance scenes. I was so happy to finally be down in the disco, but lady, I love a dance party.
我和约翰就——当你听到你说你跟编舞见过面时，我惊呆了。但他们很喜欢，所以编舞就说，好吧，就这么跳。挺好的。完美。挺好的。也许她当时想的是，我都不知道该从何开始，所以你们就做你们正在做的事吧。好吧，我得说，我很喜欢拍摄这些舞蹈场面。我很高兴终于能去迪斯科舞厅了，但是亲爱的，我太喜欢舞会了。
I know you do. And I will stay on the dance floor the whole time at your wedding. I want to be out on that dance floor, you know, for my 30th birthday, I had a dance party and I danced the whole time. And my 50th is going to be coming up in a few years and I want a dance party again. You should have a dance party. And I maybe should put on the invitation, wear comfy shoes. And I may not talk to you because I'm going to be dancing the whole time and that's what
我知道你喜欢。在你的婚礼上，我会全程待在舞池里。我想去那个舞池里，你知道的，在我30岁生日时，我办了一个舞会，我跳了整晚。我的50岁生日几年后就要到了，我还想再办一次舞会。你应该办个舞会。我或许应该在请柬上写上，请穿舒适的鞋子。我可能不会跟你说话，因为我要从头跳到尾，这就是我为我的派对所想要的。
I want for my party. But for my 40th, I was seven months pregnant with my daughter. And so Lee and I just went and had a little baby moon slash birthday. So it'll be like 20 years since I had a dance party. Well, I can't wait because I want me, you and Oscar to recreate what we did for years, which was we did all the single ladies by Beyonce, the three of us. I want all the single ladies. I want sexy back.
但在我40岁的时候，我怀着女儿已经七个月了。所以我和李只是去度了一个短暂的蜜月兼生日旅行。所以这将是我举办舞会以来的20年。好吧，我等不及了，因为我想让我、你和奥斯卡重现我们多年来一直在做的事，那就是我们三个人一起跳碧昂丝的《Single Ladies》。我想要《Single Ladies》。我想要《SexyBack》。
I want gold digger. I want some Lady Gaga. Oh yeah. I want them all. I just rewatched my wedding video because for my anniversary this year, my husband finally edited together all the footage from our wedding. Really? Yes.
我想要《Gold Digger》。我想要一些Lady Gaga的歌。哦，对。我全都要。我刚刚重新看了我的婚礼录像，因为为了我今年的结婚纪念日，我丈夫终于把我婚礼的所有素材剪辑到了一起。真的吗？是的。
He said it took him a year because he just had to work on it a little bit at a time. It's almost 30 minutes and we sat down with the kids and watched it. And it was so fun to see all of us dancing, Jenna. I mean, there were so many elements that were great, but it just warmed my heart. Like there you are on the dance floor, we're like dancing our hearts out. It's just so great. Well I want it. You're going to have it.
他说这花了他一年时间，因为他只能每次抽一点时间来处理。快30分钟了，我们和孩子们坐在一起看了它。看到我们所有人都在跳舞，真的很有趣，詹娜。我的意思是，有很多元素都很棒，但它真的很温暖我的心。就像你在舞池里一样，我们都在全心全意地跳舞。这真是太棒了。好吧，我想要这个。你一定会有的。
You're going to have a dance party. Okay, good. We painted hummingbirds for my 50th and by God, we're going to dance on your 50th. Good. Yay. I'm going to make sure it happens. Well there's one person who refuses to dance in Cafe Disco and that is Angela, but, but she's going to sway her foot a little bit to the music.
你会有一个舞会的。好吧，太好了。为了我的50岁生日，我们画了蜂鸟，上帝作证，在你的50岁生日上我们也要跳舞。好。耶。我一定会确保它发生的。好吧，有一个人拒绝在迪斯科咖啡馆跳舞，那就是安吉拉，但是，但是她会随着音乐稍微晃动一下她的脚。
She's going to tap her finger. Yeah. And Paul Stitch shared that this whole storyline of Michael starting a Cafe Disco was always going to end with this moment. I did not know that. He said that their litmus test for whether or not Michael could pull off his Cafe Disco dream was Angela because she thought that hanging out at a disco all day was completely unacceptable.
她会用手指轻轻敲击。对。保罗·斯蒂奇分享说，迈克尔创办迪斯科咖啡馆的整个故事情节注定会以这个时刻结束。我不知道这个。他说，他们用来检验迈克尔是否能实现他的迪斯科咖啡馆梦想的试金石就是安吉拉，因为她认为整天泡在迪斯科舞厅里是完全不可接受的。
She was the lone holdout through most of the show and Michael, if you notice, keeps checking in with her, checking in with her, trying to engage her. So in the end, that little tap and that little foot sway, that is Michael's victory. That's his big win. And Warren shared, by the way, that in his mind, he thought that this moment actually is the beginning of an evolution for the character of Angela, that this moment that shows how severe and closed off her character can be, but it's a baby step toward her maybe opening up to new possibilities.
在整个节目的绝大部分时间里，她都是唯一的坚持者，如果你注意到的话，迈克尔一直在关注她，关注她，试图让她参与进来。所以最后，那个轻轻的敲击和那个小小的脚部晃动，就是迈克尔的胜利。那是他的大获全胜。沃伦还分享说，顺便，在他看来，他认为这个时刻实际上是安吉拉这个角色演变的开始，这个时刻展现了她的性格可以多么严厉和封闭，但这只是她可能向新可能性敞开心扉的一小步。
Ooh, I like that. So this moment was very rich in their outline and their writing of this episode. And very thought out. Mm-hmm. Well, I went to the script. I wanted to see what was in the shooting draft for this moment. There was a Michael voiceover. Here's what it says in the script.
噢，我喜欢这个。所以这个时刻在他们这一集的提纲和剧本编写中非常丰富。而且考虑得很周到。嗯-hmm。好吧，我查阅了剧本。我想看看这一集的拍摄初稿里有什么。有一个迈克尔的画外音。剧本里是这样写的。
Michael sits with Angela. He looks around the room and takes in all of the dancing couples, Jim and Pam, Phyllis and Bob, Kelly and Andy, and Kevin and Lynn, who are furiously making out. Michael notices Angela is tapping her foot to the music and he smiles to himself. And this is the voiceover that would then play. They needed me. I left. I will never let them down again.
迈克尔和安吉拉坐在一起。他环顾房间，将所有跳舞的夫妻尽收眼底，吉姆和帕姆、菲利斯和鲍勃、凯利和安迪，还有疯狂热吻的凯文和琳。迈克尔注意到安吉拉正随着音乐用脚打拍子，他暗自微笑。接着是随后播放的画外音。他们需要我。我离开了。我再也不会让他们失望了。
I will always be there for them. I will be at every important moment of their lives, their births, their deaths, their babies, their hospital stuff, no matter where or whether they want me there or not for them. That actually made me get a little choked up. I know. Isn't that so sweet? I really wish that had been in. I know.
我将永远陪伴着他们。我将出现在他们生命中的每一个重要时刻，他们的出生、他们的死亡、他们的孩子、他们的医院事务，不管在哪里，也不管他们是否想要我在那里。这实际上让我有点哽咽。我知道。是不是很甜？我真的希望那一幕能被剪进去。我知道。
I thought that was really sweet. One other thing I want to share is that when we were filming in Cafe Disco and trying to figure out this moment of how Michael would see my foot swaying, my finger tapping, we shot just a quick little tag that didn't make it in. And everyone has left Cafe Disco and only Angela Martin is in there cleaning. And Michael walks by and she is dancing as she cleans. Why do I remember this? We just shot it really quickly and just as an alt, just in case.
我觉得那真的很甜。我想分享的另一件事是，当我们正在迪斯科咖啡馆拍摄并试图弄清楚迈克尔如何看到我的脚在晃动、手指在敲击这个时刻时，我们拍了一个没有被采用的快速小彩蛋。每个人都离开了迪斯科咖啡馆，只有安吉拉·马丁在那里打扫卫生。迈克尔走过，而她边打扫边跳舞。为什么我还记得这个？我们只是快速拍了一下，作为一个备选，以防万一。
Yeah. Like you actually respond to the music when everybody's left, but it's still that victory. He's still got you. Yeah. It didn't make it in. It's not in the shooting draft. It's not in deleted scenes. But that was an alt that they shot.
对。就像当所有人都离开后，你真的对音乐做出了反应，但那依然是那种胜利。他还是把你拿下了。对。它没有被剪进去。拍摄初稿里没有。被删减的片段里也没有。但这确实是他们拍摄的一个备选镜头。
I wonder if we were all like waiting in the hallway while you did that or something because I have such a memory of it. It was really quick. We just sort of grabbed it in the moment. But of course the actual tag that made it in, which is so great, is Kelly piercing Andy's ear in the restroom. This really lends itself to that idea that they could be a couple. I know.
我在想，当时我们是不是都在走廊里等你们完成那个动作，因为我对这个记忆太深刻了。非常快。我们当时只是顺手把它拍了下来。但当然，真正被剪进去并大获成功的彩蛋是，凯莉在洗手间里给安迪穿耳洞。这真的很符合他们可能会成为一对的这个想法。我知道。
Because this is a very cute coupley thing. It is. Halstead said that they actually did a take where Mindy, as Kelly, fully pierces Andy's ear and it was painful and bloody and a mess, but they cut it for time. Well, that's it, guys. That's Cafe Disco. It is. And it was so fun.
因为这是一件非常可爱的情侣会做的事。确实如此。霍尔斯特德说，他们实际上拍了一个版本，明迪饰演的凯莉真的给安迪把耳洞穿透了，过程既痛苦又血腥还一团糟，但为了时长被剪掉了。好了，就这些了，各位。这就是迪斯科咖啡馆。是的。真的太有趣了。
I loved rewatching this. Thank you so much to Warren Lieberstein and Halstead Sullivan, Randy Cordray for giving us all kinds of fun behind the scenes details. And Lady, before we go, you know how at the beginning of the episodes we always say, like, when do you listen? Where do you listen? You always say good morning and then you remember that people might not listen in the morning. Yes.
我很喜欢重看这一集。非常感谢沃伦·利伯斯坦、霍尔斯特德·萨利文和兰迪·科德雷为我们提供各种有趣的幕后细节。亲爱的，在我们离开之前，你知道我们在每集开头总是会问，比如，你们什么时候听？你们在哪里听？你总是先说早上好，然后才想起来人们可能不是在早上听的。是的。
Well, we got a letter from Katie C, who is 14 years old, lives in the UK. And she said, I listen to Office Ladies whilst delivering newspapers every day and it makes it so much more fun when it's raining or way too warm for my ginger jeans. I know I have the podcast to keep me going and I never give up. I love that. Well, hi, Katie. Hi, Katie. Good luck today on your paper route.
嗯，我们收到了一封来自凯蒂·C的信，她14岁，住在英国。她说，我每天在送报纸的时候听《办公室淑女》，这让下雨天或者对我的姜黄色牛仔裤来说太热的天气变得有趣多了。我知道我有这个播客陪伴我前行，我永远不会放弃。我太喜欢这个了。嗯，嗨，凯蒂。嗨，凯蒂。祝你今天的送报路线一切顺利。
Be safe. And Jenna and I are sending you big hugs. Thanks for listening to Office Ladies. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer.
注意安全。我和詹娜给你一个大大的拥抱。感谢收听《办公室淑女》。感谢收听《办公室淑女》。《办公室淑女》由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。
And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的副制片人是 Ainsley Bubicoe。我们的主题曲是 Creed Bratton 的《Rubber Tree》。有关《Office Ladies》的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。在 Stitcher Premium 免费试用一个月，请使用代码：Office。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。